Ja, wobei, eine Sache sag ich mal noch kurz. Also ich hab ja bei Pavel sozusagen bei Artcom ja das Extreme Programming auch noch mal in reinen Kultur erlebt, glaube ich zwei oder drei Jahre lang. Und ich finde auch tatsächlich noch, dass das einer der charmanteren Implementierungen von diesem ganzen Agile ist, weil es gibt wirklich tausende Spielarten jetzt davon. Und manche sind dann auch schon wieder so selbstverliebt in ihre Prozesse, dass es so wirkt wie, die haben sich das jetzt ausgedacht, um auch selbst erhaltende Maßnahmen, dass es auch diese Scrum Master und Consultants und so weiter auch immer schön weitergeben kann, die die neuesten Methoden dann vertreiben können. Wie auch immer, was aber auch ein großer Punkt dabei ist, finde ich schon, ist auch so diese Feedback-Schleife nicht nur für Kundengespräche oder sonst was, sondern für sich selber. Weil man halt durch diese kurzen Iteration oder Sprints, wie es dann so schön heißt, halt auch immer sehr schön selber sich den Spiegel vorhält, wie gut oder wie schlecht Dinge laufen und sozusagen nicht erst nach drei Jahren feststellt, oh, irgendwie war alles kacke und wir sind gegen die Wand gefahren, sondern sozusagen durch diese kurzen Feedback-Prozesse schneller vielleicht merkt, dass irgendwas schief läuft und darauf reagieren kann. Also auch wieder so agil, ne?
Ich glaube, das sind noch zwei Punkte, die für mich bei Scrum oder weshalb ich oft versuche, so Projekte so ähnlich zu organisieren, ist erstmal der ständige Verbesserungsprozess, dass du eben nach einem Sprint, dass du jetzt abgeschlossen bist, und ich ist mir jetzt erstmal egal, aber du hast auf der Meta-Ebene einen Verbesserungsprozess, weil danach sprichst du mit dem Team darüber, was lief in dem Sprint gut und was lief schlecht und was wollen wir weiter machen. Das geht eigentlich nur um Arbeitsabläufe. Das heißt, eigentlich das Meeting überschreibt der Scrum Master auf, was er noch tun kann, damit das Team besser arbeiten kann. Und in der nächsten Woche werden dann überprüft, hat das geklappt und was können wir weiter verbessern auf der Meta-Ebene, wie wir zusammenarbeiten. Da sind dann oft ganz komische Sachen wie, wenn ich meinen PR, wenn ich einen PR- und Pull-Request stelle, kriegt im Moment das keiner mit. Und wer soll dann die Code-Review machen? Keiner fühlt sich verantwortlich und eine Verbesserung wäre dann, wir weisen das extra jemandem zu. Und im nächsten Sprint kann man dann sehen, wird das jetzt so gemacht. Und das finde ich an Scrum extrem hilfreich. Und dann noch dieses Denken aus User-Stories.
Also, ja gut, aber das ist ja, ich vermute mal, wenn du im Team arbeitest, auch wenn du zu zweit oder zu dritt bist, dann kommst du ja so oder so auf Verbesserungsvorschläge, wenn du bestimmte Qualitätsmerkmale irgendwie einhalten möchtest. Aber was ich an diesen Methoden eigentlich ganz charmant finde, ist, dass du nicht nur versuchst, wie du entwickelst zu verändern, sondern auch das Produkt, für das du entwickelst, muss ja geeignet sein, um überhaupt mit Scrum bearbeitet zu werden. Das heißt, da gibt es da so eine ganz natürliche Teilung zwischen dem Scrum Master oder was auch immer, der hier derjenige, der irgendwie für die Teamgesundheit und auch die Teaminteressen zuständig ist. Und da steht er eigentlich in direkten Konflikt mit dem Product Owner, dem er das eigentlich das Team ziemlich egal lässt, sondern der möchte ja, dass sein Produkt endlich fertig wird. Und das ist so eine Teilung, die, glaube ich, sehr wertvoll ist, weil es funktioniert halt nicht, irgendwie dann den 10. Coding Monkey dahin zu setzen und zu hoffen, dass du schneller wirst. Weil so funktioniert halt die Entwicklung nicht, weil das ist ein sozialer Prozess.
Und es fällt sehr schnell auf, dass es nicht funktioniert in so einem Scrum Prozess.
Aber es wird immer wieder versucht.
Okay, was ist jetzt die Definition von Scrum Master? Also was ist das für eine Rolle?
Es gibt drei Rollen im Team. Und der Scrum Master ist, also es gibt das Team, das sind die Entwickler, manchmal Designer und so weiter, die Leute, die arbeiten tatsächlich. Die am Produkt arbeiten, meinte ich. Dann gibt es den Product Owner, der ist so eigentlich der Kunde im Schluss. Der sagt, wie soll das Produkt sein? Der pflegt, der sagt, aus was für Features soll das Produkt bestellen? Welche User-Stories wollen wir erfüllen?
So ein bisschen die Requirements.
Priorisiert auch die Requirements, sagt aber nicht, was schaffen wir in der nächsten Woche? Und auch, wie implementieren wir das? Das ist nur die Team-Aufgabe. Und dann gibt es als drittes den Scrum Master. Als drittes von vielleicht vier, weil Manager sind auch noch dabei. Und der ist eigentlich nur dafür zuständig, dass das Team arbeiten kann. Das heißt, wenn immer mal der Monitor nicht funktioniert oder einer sagt, heute war es schon wieder zu laut, ist der Scrum Master der, der eigentlich machen muss, dass der Team-Member arbeiten kann. Der ist der Tank in der Gruppe. Der sagt auch, wenn der Product Owner sagt, wir brauchen das, muss der Scrum Master eigentlich aufstehen und sagen, wenn das Team sagt, das passt nicht in den Sprint und wir wollen lieber erst Bugs fixen oder müssen erst Bugs fixen, dann geht das jetzt nicht.
Also der hält sozusagen dem Team den Rücken frei gegenüber der Produktseite, sozusagen der Mittelsmann zwischen Umsetzung und...
Also es ist eigentlich eine rein soziale Rolle.
Ja gut, der muss auch viel arbeiten. Der muss vor allem die Jira so einrichten, dass es funktioniert zum Beispiel.
Der kriegt es auch von beiden Seiten meistens. Also die Entwickler kotzen sich bei ihm aus, aber auch das Product Management. Also das ist keine einfache Rolle.
Haben wir da noch eine Vakanz im Potluff-Projekt? Ich würde gerade sagen, das ist bei uns irgendwie. Ich bin aber auch für das Soziale gesamt zuständig.
Und dann Priorisieren und Manager, würde ich sagen. Aber Scrum Master solltest du nicht sein, weil der Scrum Master darf eigentlich nie mit dem Product Owner zusammenfallen.
Das ist ein Interessenkonflikt.
Aber Tims multiple Persönlichkeiten...
Stimmt, mit ein bisschen Sympathie.
Gut und bett, Tim läuft es auch. Ja, ich mein, was halt auch sozusagen ein Teil dieses ganzen Prozesses ist, ist ja dann, der Product Owner oder die Product Ownerin möchte jetzt so schnell wie möglich das Produkt haben. Und die anderen sagen dann ja, Moment, hohoho, wenn wir das ordentlich machen müssen, dann dauert das aber ein bisschen. Und jetzt nicht so hier mit der heißen Nadel. Also da gibt es ja immer diesen Zeitkonflikt auch zwischen so schnell wie möglich haben wollen, aber auch so gut wie möglich bauen. Und da gibt es ja dann eben auch diese Frage dann, ok, wann kann ich denn dieses Feature haben? Und dann wird geschätzt, so über einen Daumen gepeilt, ja, keine Ahnung, zwei Wochen und so weiter. Bei dem Extreme Programming fand ich den Teil auch sehr cool eigentlich, weil für jedes Feature musste dann geschätzt werden, wie innovativ es ist und wie komplex es ist. Also Innovationsfaktor war von null bis zwei. Und zwar hat man es schon mal gemacht, hat man, also und weiß sozusagen super wie es geht, dann ist sozusagen Innovation null, dann war es irgendwie, ja, hat man irgendwie schon mal so grob verstanden, aber jetzt lange nicht mehr gemacht, also muss man auf jeden Fall noch mal was nachgucken oder komplett unbekanntes Feld noch nie, diese Programmiersprache verwendet und so weiter. Das war der eine und die Komplexität war sozusagen dann, okay, ja, mache ich in fünf Minuten, mache ich an einem Tag, mache ich an mehr als einem Tag sozusagen. Und das hat Artcom dann über Jahre getrackt. Also die haben diese Karten, wir haben es auch auf Karten gemacht, und die haben diese Karten getrackt, und wie lange die Features auch wirklich gedauert haben, und kam dann auf einen Entwickler-Verschätzfaktor von 2.1 oder irgendwie sowas, Pabli wüsste das jetzt wahrscheinlich ziemlich genau. Aber es war sozusagen so, dass dann die Manager dann den Kunden quasi das, was die Entwickler geschätzt haben, nochmal zwei gerechnet haben, um dann so auf einigermaßen einen grünen Weg zu kommen. Aber das fand ich, da gibt es auch verschiedenste Varianten, wie so die Teams oder die Methodiken dann ihre Schätzungen abliefern. Aber wenn man sich zumindest mal auf ein Konzept geeinigt hat und das konsequent durchzieht, dann ist das halt auch, wie gesagt, eine Feedback-Loop für sich selber, um zu sehen, ok, so ein Feature in etwa haben wir schon mal gebaut, mit so einer Komplexität, jetzt hab ich auch ein besseres Gefühl, wie ich das einschätzen kann. Und auf der anderen Seite ist das dann für diesen Scrum Master oder wie auch immer dann, wie es jeweils heißt, auch gut, weil dann ein bisschen sicherer bestimmte Schätzungen an Kunden kommuniziert werden können. Und das sind alles so Aspekte, die ich auf jeden Fall durchaus positiv aus diesem agilen Software-Entwicklungs-Dingsbumms rausziehen würde.
Wenn es richtig gemacht ist.
Ich wollte auch noch eine Sache zu Letty sagen. Ich benutze auch diese Bewertung von User-Stories benutze ich seit Jahren jetzt auch für die Angebotserstellung. Also immer wenn mich jemand sagt, ich habe hier diese riesen Web-App, schreibe ich erst mal auf, was sind das für User-Stories. Manchmal sind es auch Entwickler-Stories wie ich will einen Entwicklungsprozess haben oder so. Und dann bewerte ich das auch genauso mit den Story-Punkten, die ich eigentlich immer für meinen Scrum bewerte. Ich habe halt so einen Story-Punkt-Value im Kopf oder mehrere. So einen für Kunden, die viel in Südendurchland sind. Na ja, weiß ich nicht. Aber es gibt mehrere. Keine Ahnung für, ja. Und so kann ich das eigentlich echt gut bewerten und komme da eigentlich immer ganz gut aus mit meinen Angeboten, wie die dann aufgehen.
Also ich finde es interessant, dass man quasi die Innovation da noch mit rein bringt als Punktwert, weil das bei diesen aktuellen Story-Punkt-Schätzungen, oder so wie ich das kenne, meistens ist es ja so ein Misch aus Komplexität, die man schätzt, ne? Viele sagen so, ja, wenn du das aber auf Tage runterrechnen würdest, darum geht es nicht. Ich schätze hier nicht, wie lange ich es brauche, dafür das zu implementieren, sondern wie komplex das ist. Und oft ist es ja so, wenn man kleinere Teams hat, dann sind die Rollen, na gut, kommt drauf an, kann auch bei größeren Teams passieren, dann schätzen bestimmte Leute anders für bestimmte Stories als andere Leute das machen. Was dann zu dem Problem wird, wenn dann die Person Urlaub hat. Und dann ist die Story drinnen und dann hast du eine Schätzung, die überhaupt nicht hinhaut. Weil der eine würde halt für diese eine Story irgendwie einen Tag brauchen, oder ich mein, wegen 20 Gummi-Punkte und der andere 40 Gummi-Punkte.
Aber da unterhält man sich doch eigentlich drüber.
Ja, da gibt es ja das Backlog-Refinement bzw. das Sprintplanning. Ich hab schon beides gesehen, da gibt es auch noch solche.
Ja, ich bin auf jeden Fall, also ich hab's ziemlich cool schon implementiert gesehen. Ich fand's bei Artcom zum Beispiel tatsächlich relativ streng und auch konsequent implementiert und das hat dann auch relativ gut funktioniert. Und bei VUGA hatte ich auch so ein, zwei Teams, wo es wirklich so viel wie nötig und so wenig wie möglich sozusagen Prozess da war. Aber jetzt auch so in letzter Zeit hab ich auch ganz viel von, wie gesagt, wo das Agile gar nicht mehr so agil wirkt und der Prozess schon so überbordend ist, dass man am Ende eigentlich gar nicht mehr zum Entwickeln vor lauter Meetings und Prozessbesprechungen usw. kommt. Also auch das ist kein Allheilmittel gegen die üblichen Krankheiten. Dann stellen die sich hin und sagen, total agil. Dann gibt es aber ein Sprint-Planning, das geht fast zwei Drittel des Tages. Dann werden die Tickets noch mal gegrumpt und dann kann es passieren, dass das Backlog leer ist. Dann verfällt die halbe Firma in Panik, oh Gott, das Backlog ist leer. Jetzt müssen wir ein neues Meeting machen, um es wieder zu füllen. Und man denkt sich so, Leute, Agil. Aber da gibt es dann auch wieder alle Spielarten. Aus meiner Erfahrung ist es dann wirklich wichtig, dass man so einen guten Organisator hat, ob das jetzt Grum Master oder was auch immer ist, und das dann halt auch möglichst konsequent durchzieht und nicht nur so auf halber Arschbacke.
Ja und vor allem einfach guckt, was zu den Projekten passt, zu dem Team passt. Und wenn es halt eine Mischung aus mehreren Welten ist, wo man einfach die perfekte Adaption gefunden hat, dann ist es eben das. Also es ist halt nicht so ein One-Fits-All-Prozess oder...
Es ist halt auch mittlerweile so eine Beraterindustrie für sich geworden. Deswegen wird das jetzt heutzutage auch wieder dieses ganze Agile schon wieder ein bisschen so verteufelt, vielleicht aber sehr kritisch gesehen, weil...
Es ist halt so ein bisschen so ein Basswirt teilweise, dieses Grum gewesen.
Ja, das ist so wie... Wir sind jetzt auch in der Amazon Cloud, weil alle anderen machen das auch. Und wir machen jetzt auch Agile, und dann kaufen wir uns jetzt irgendwelche Agile Consultants ein und die beraten uns jetzt, wie man das am besten macht. Und dann ist das aber selten wirklich gut.
Aber wenn man dann Entwicklerinnen oder Entwickler fragt, dann sagen die einem ja recht schnell, ob der Prozess irgendwie dann nett ist oder nicht.
Was macht denn einen guten Scrum Master aus? Oder eine... Was ist denn die weibliche...
Wenn ich mir hier dieses Bild angucke zu Scrum, dann passt das ja schon fast ganz gut. Hier im Chat wurde so ein Bild zu Software Development gepostet, wo so die verschiedenen Prozesse versinnbildlicht werden und es ist natürlich sehr überzeichnet, aber es sind ein paar Wahrheiten. Hoffentlich schafft es das in den Show Notes, sodass die Hörer das dann auch später konsumieren können.
Das ist schon so gut wie drin.
Ich würde erst einmal sagen, dass es wichtig ist, dass der Scrum Master nur Scrum Master ist und nicht noch im Team oder am besten noch Product Owner oder Manager ist.
Aber er muss halt auch so ein gewisses Verständnis von Softwareentwicklung haben. Also es geht halt auch nicht, dass man jemanden hat, der nie entwickelt hat. Du musst halt auch so diesen kompletten Prozess verstehen und vor allen Dingen auch wenn die Leute mit dir reden, du musst so ein bisschen die Enter halt auch sein, wenn jemand mal vielleicht nicht weiterkommt und dich anspricht.
Und du musst durchsetzen. Also ich hab das mal eine Zeit lang gemacht für mein Team und ich glaube meine Schwäche war auf jeden Fall, dass ich mich nicht so durchsetzen konnte gegenüber anderen dann außerhalb des Teams. Also du musst schon dann auch für das Team einstehen können.
In unserer oder meiner letzten Firma war der Scram Master in Spanien und der hat wirklich den Posten auch gelebt und ich hab den auch sich oft vor uns mit dem Product oder sich anschreien sehen, weil der hat das dann halt auch wirklich eskaliert, wenn da irgendwas nicht funktioniert.
Das ist auch richtig so. Und du brauchst natürlich einen ganz großen Koffer mit so Sachen wie Post-its und einer Uhr, eine analogen, die abläuft.
Malen wäre auch gut.
Gut malen kann diese ganzen Sachen nicht.
Wart ihr das ernst? Nee, das wirklich jetzt. Die Methoden, gerade jetzt aus dem Entwickler-Volk, irgendwie so Verbesserungen gerade in der Retro rauszukitzeln, das ist schon gar nicht so einfach.
Da muss man sich auch immer wieder was Neues einfallen lassen, weil die werden nach so einer Zeit faul und schreiben immer auf dieselben Fragen, dieselben Antworten auf und so weiter.
Da gibt es wirklich eine ganze Reihe an Methoden, die die haben, um beispielsweise so Verbesserungen oder an bestimmte ursächliche Probleme im Entwicklungsprozess heranzukommen. Das reicht ja nicht, wenn du ihm fragst, was ist denn jetzt aus deiner Sicht scheiße gelaufen, dann ist das ja eine sehr subjektive Einsicht oder Ansicht eines Entwicklers. Vielleicht gibt es da irgendwie im Hintergrund etwas anderes, was das eigentlich auslöst. Und das muss das Gramm-Master halt irgendwie rauskitzeln können.
Klingt so, als ob ein Psychologiestudium eine Frage ist.
Und das Negativbeispiel wäre dann wieder Leute, die versuchen, diese sozialen Probleme mit technischen Lösungen anzugehen. Das gibt es natürlich dann auch. Das schlägt dann meistens fehl. Ich kann zu diesem Thema, das habe ich schon mal empfohlen, das Buch, das hat mir der Ron empfohlen. Security Nightmares Ron. Und zwar heißt das Buch Peopleware. Ich glaube, ich habe das schon mal hier erwähnt.
Nein, ich hätte das nicht gemeint.
Moment, ich poste das hier gerade nochmal in die Show Notes. Dann hat Tim wieder einen schönen Affiliate-Link.
Als ob es darum jetzt ankommen würde.
Na, die Pizza muss ja auch irgendwie bezahlt werden. Weil, was ich sozusagen als Qualitätsmerkmal sehe, ist, inwieweit die Person in der Lage ist, halt dem Team den Rücken freizuhalten und diesen Flow halt aufrechtzuerhalten, dass die auch wirklich zum entwickeln kommen und nicht in tausenden Meetings sitzen oder sich zu sehr mit dem Prozess beschäftigen müssen, sondern wie gesagt so wenig wie nötig, ne, so viel wie nötig und so wenig wie möglich vom Prozess sozusagen. Und dieses Buch, behandelt im Prinzip, ist auch schon relativ alt, aber immer wieder mit neuen Auflagen und neuen Erkenntnissen aufgefrischt, behandelt eben genau diesen Flow in der Softwareentwicklung. Und das, ich hab's bestimmt schon mal erzählt, aber das ist von einer Software Consultancy, die sozusagen mal ihre großen Projekte haben Revue passieren lassen und meinten so, 80% unserer Projekte sind irgendwelche wahren Wirtschaftssysteme. Und so und so viel Prozent davon sind entweder dauernd zu lange oder schlagen ganz fehl. Und es liegt nicht daran, dass dieses Problem nicht lösbar ist, weil das Problem ist schon lange gelöst. Und mit der fortschreitenden Technologie müsste es wenn dann einfacher werden als schwerer. Das heißt, die Technik ist nicht das Problem, jetzt mal ein Wirtschaftssystem zu bauen. Es muss also irgendwie soziologisch eher zu erklären sein. Und haben sozusagen aus ihren Projekten das mal Revue passieren lassen und haben auch schon erste Experimente bei ihren Kunden gemacht. Und dann war die erste Auflage auch ein ziemlich guter Erfolg und ich glaube, dass was sie sozusagen mit dem Buch über die Jahre verdient haben, haben sie dann einfach in weitere solche Studien und Experimente, um ihre Thesen zu validieren, fließen lassen, sodass dann halt auch wirklich echt coole Versuche sozusagen dabei sind zu diesem ganzen Flow-Thema. Na ja, guter Blick in Zeit.
Kann man da auch was fürs Leben lernen?
Ich finde, wirklich eins der besten Bücher, was ich so gelesen habe in diesem Kontext, weil ganz oft ist es auch so, dass solche Bücher, gerade von den Amis, einfach auch so, die haben dann immer so eine große Message und die wiederholen sie tausende Male, immer wieder reiben sie dir dieses Mantra rein und denkst dir so, ja, ich hab's verstanden, erzähl mir jetzt was Neues. Ah nee, nächstes Kapitel fängt wieder so an. Und das ist wirklich to the point, zack, zack, zack, einfach jedes Thema konkret und korrekt behandelt. Das ist auch für alle Liebhaber, das Großraumbüros und Open Space Office oder wie auch immer, Open Plan. Da gibt es auch eine wirklich fantastische Abhandlung dazu. Die werden sich alle sehr freuen. Ich kann das wirklich nur empfehlen.
Ich hab mal unten drunter das andere Buch von Tom DeMarco verlinkt. Deadline heißt das und da geht es halt auch um Projektmanagement und wie man Projekte runter bricht. Also ich hab die deutsche Edition davon, das hat uns halt auch, ich meine, Professorin für Softwareentwicklung und Softwarequalität empfohlen. Und das ist halt auch ganz interessant so dieses Herunterbrechen von Software, wie man entwickelt und dass du halt auch irgendwann an einen Punkt kommst, wo du kannst halt noch so viele Leute an der Stelle einstellen, es bringt nichts mehr. Und das ist halt echt auch ganz cool gewesen, um das mal durchzulesen.
Was ich noch interessant finde an diesem agilen Projektmanagement in Verbindung mit wenn man Angestellte hat oder wenn man selbst angestellt ist, ist, dass zwar dann das ganze Tagesgeschäft agil abläuft, und du als Team verantwortlich bist und Teil eines Teams und so weiter bist, aber individuelle Ziele hast, für meistens Personalziele. Und da habe ich damals auch recht viel gelesen, wie man halt, als wir unsere Mitarbeiter eingestellt hatten, damals wie man eben diesen Scrum-Ansatz eben dann so machen kann, dass es nicht individuelle Personalziele sind, sondern da wieder, oder dass es, das Team ist ja eigentlich verantwortlich, dass das dann da wieder rausgerechnet wird. Da gibt es auch so ein paar Ansätze, wie man eben wie sein Personal managen und wie heißt das denn? Personalmanagement? HR sind die ganzen Ziele. Ich war ja nie angestellt. Aber ja, dieses, dass man das eben auch auf diesen agilen Softwareentwicklungsprozess dann anpasst. Und vielleicht ist deswegen auch oft Scrum nicht richtig implementiert oder nicht in den Köpfen drin, weil wenn jeder individuelle Ziele hat, aber im Team sich für das ganze Team verantwortlich fühlen soll, clasht das eben manchmal.
Na ich glaube, wenn das Team gut funktioniert oder wenn klar wird, dass man ein ähnliches Ziel verfolgt, dann und viel ist es ja auch oder viel wert ist ja auch, sich damit zu identifizieren, was man gerade macht.
Davon handelt zum Beispiel auch dieses People Wear Buch ganz viel, dass diese Identifikation der Entwickler mit dem Produkt, was sie entwickeln, da sein muss, weil sonst sind alle so, ist mir egal, ich hack das jetzt da irgendwie rein. Und wie man sozusagen auch diese Identifikation mit dem Produkt herstellt und das fand ich da auch sehr schön zusammengefasst, weil im Prinzip alle von uns kennen das bestimmt, weil es bestimmt mal gute und schlechte Projekte war, wo das da war, aber da war das mal so auf den Punkt ausformuliert, dass man so seinen eigenen Denkprozess auch mal so abschließen konnte. Aber ja, genau, das ist oft der Knackpunkt. Na, bist du jetzt informiert zum Thema?
Da können wir auch noch weitere Stunden drüber.
Na ja, gut, dazu sind wir ja hier.
Können wir zur Open Source-Entwicklung dann mal rüber switchen in dem Kontext?
Ja, guter Punkt eigentlich. Das frage ich mich halt die ganze Zeit. Also erstmal frage ich mich, hat sich eigentlich was verbessert? Also ist eigentlich irgendwas wirklich besser geworden? Oder werden nur mehr Konzepte herumgereicht und man macht die ganze Zeit so einen Hexentanz um neue Modelle und am Ende scheitert alles genauso wie vorher? Oder ist eigentlich irgendwas wirklich toller geworden?
Es kommt doch ganz sehr darauf an, in was für einem Team du arbeitest und wie dein Team zusammengesetzt ist.
Generell meine ich so.
Aber wenn ich jetzt so sehe, wie in den 80ern und so Software entwickelt wurde und wie so die Büros und so weiter aussahen und wie sie da mit Anzügen saßen oder die amerikanische Cubicle Welt und so, die ja immer noch in Teilen sicherlich existiert, aber da würde ich sagen, hat sich schon einiges zum Besseren geändert.
Von den Arbeitsbedingungen her meinst du?
Ja und auch generell arbeitsweise.
Softwarequalität?
Ich meine Produktivität, also ich hätte jetzt vielleicht Produktivität sogar noch als erstes gesagt. Ist halt schwer, weil ich jetzt nicht so eine Dekadenlange Vergleichsmöglichkeit habe. Ich habe ja direkt sozusagen Agil und so weiter angefangen. Und Qualität, also da ist auch, es ist, finde ich, immer schwer zu beurteilen, ob das eine jetzt wirklich so viel besser ist als das andere. Gefühlt halte ich, also ich halte den Prozess zum Beispiel auch gerade, was ja mit diesem Ruby, mit dieser Rubywelle da an oder losging, wo das eben auch wieder agile sein sollte, war ja auch dieses Test Driven-Development, was es auch schon prinzipiell als Idee mal gab, aber nie wirklich umgesetzt oder gelebt wurde. Und die Ruby-Leute, die haben ja so richtig da mal was gewuppt, sag ich mal. Und gerade in der Community war das wirklich dann ein sehr starker Strom und ich finde schon, dass das auf jeden Fall auch zur Verbesserung der Softwarequalität beigetragen hat. Natürlich auch da gibt es wieder die Leute, die es dann schleifen lassen und wo es dann, ja ich hab auch einen Test geschrieben. Achievement unlocked, aber es gibt halt die, die das konsequent durchziehen und da würde ich sagen, bringt das auf jeden Fall was im Vergleich zu, ja es steht in der Spezifikation, dass es funktionieren muss, also verlassen wir uns jetzt mal drauf.
Du veränderst auch stark deine Denkweise, wenn du testdriven arbeitest. Ich hab so in der Tat angefangen eigentlich zu arbeiten, testdriven und bei mir ist es leider immer weiter runtergegangen, je weiter ich in andere Teams gekommen bin, weil es gibt, jetzt finde ich den Großteil im Web scheint, sich nicht rumzuscheren irgendwie, dass du halt gute, qualitativ hochwertige Software schreibst. Aber dieses testdriven zu arbeiten und in diese Denkweise reinzukommen, dass du dir vorher Gedanken machst, was musst du für Funktionen bauen, was erwartest du von den Funktionen. Du hast halt so ein anderes mentales Modell von deiner Software, die du dann baust und machst dir noch mal über so ein paar Dinge vorher schon Gedanken, bevor du so in das, ach dann lass mich doch gleich mal Koden hinein stolperst. Und das, finde ich, hilft halt auch unwahrscheinlich so, den Blick so ein bisschen zu verändern, auf den eigentlichen, also zu fokussieren auf die Probleme, die du dann in der Software haben könntest auch.
Also was ich entscheidend finde bei dem Aspekt, ob sich die Qualität verbessert hat oder nicht, ist, wie viel Verantwortung das Team bekommt. Das heißt, wenn das Team am Ende die Software auch selber mit betreiben muss, das was Hooker als DevOps schon angesprochen hat, dann ist das ein ganz anderes Spiel, als ob du irgendwie deinen Code runterschreibst, das dann abgibst und irgendwer muss das dann für dich betreiben. Weil wenn du nämlich irgendwie in der Nacht rausgeklingelt wirst, dann überlegst du dir das nächste Mal dreimal, ob du dann nicht vielleicht doch mal ein paar Mettests dafür schreibst.
Und das haben wir bei VUGA und deswegen habe ich auch immer noch sehr romantische Erinnerungen an gerade die VUGA Anfangszeit. Da wurde nämlich alles sehr konsequent und by the book gemacht. Und da war es ja so, dass wir die Backends geschrieben haben und wir haben die Betrieben, wir haben uns die Infrastruktur selber ausgesagt. Wir durften uns die Provider oder die Hoster selber aussuchen. Und wir waren halt auch on call. Und wenn wir uns dann, vielleicht waren wir total begeistert für irgendeine neue Hippe-Technologie, aber dann, wenn es darum ging, ja, würde ich jetzt für die neue Hippe-Technologie um 2,5,4 Uhr morgens aufgeweckt werden vom Telefon, vielleicht nicht. Gehen wir mal den etwas sicheren oder battle-tested Pass, sagen wir mal. Und da war wirklich so die Mentalität, also wir hatten eine extrem hohe, ja wie sagt man, Ownership of Deutsch, also wir waren verantwortlich. Wir haben uns sehr verantwortlich gefühlt und sehr involviert und hatten uns dementsprechend auch sehr viel mehr bemüht, da eine entsprechende Qualität abzuliefern. Und ich kenne das genau, ich war jetzt auch so in zwei Projekten, wo wieder noch so diese klassische Trennung zwischen Entwicklung und Betrieb herrschte. Und es war wieder dieses klassische über einen Zaun werfen und die einen seine, ja, ihr habt so einen Scheiß programmiert, ja, ihr irgendwie Admins, kümmert euch mal gefälligst hier das irgendwie am Laufen zu halten und so, ihr seid doch Operations. Und dann gibt es so diese Grabenkriege, da denkst du so, muss auch nicht sein, geht auch anders. Aber diese, zum Beispiel diese Verantwortung, die muss man dann eben auch als Firma oder als Organisation auch bereit sein, sozusagen zu geben.
Du musst halt Fehler akzeptieren können.
Aber das hat zum Beispiel bei Buga wirklich extrem gut funktioniert.
Also ich grübel die ganze Zeit über das Verhältnis des Beitrages zu einem Gelingen eines Projektes in dem Spannungsfeld innere Organisation und Motivation. Also wie viel kann man an mangelnder Motivation wettmachen durch eine gute Organisation? In gewisser Hinsicht ist ja sowas wie ein Scrum Master. Wenn ich es euch nicht komplett falsch verstanden habe, auch jemand, der sozusagen auch alle bei Laune halten soll, der sozusagen, also vielleicht nicht so eine intrinsische Motivation gegenüber dem Projekt, aber die Gesamtmotivationslage hängt ja auch von externen Faktoren ab. Also das ist sozusagen ein Teil, wie sehr ich Motivation organisiere und wie viel hängt davon ab, dass man schlicht mit dem Herzen dranhängen muss. Und ich erinnere mich gerade an den Talk letztes Jahr über den Apollo 11 Computer. Wie hießen wir? Also ich meine, wie lang ist das jetzt her? 40 Jahre? Und? Und eine Technologie, die so im Maßstab heutiger Leistungsfähigkeit von Elektronik, jeder USB Stick ist irgendwie ein Rechenzentrum dagegen. Und dann kriegt man so präsentiert, wie viel einerseits, also wie viel Flexibilität in diesem Code drin war. Also das müsst ihr euch mal angucken, wer das jetzt nicht angeschaut hat. Also das ist irre. Also alle nur erdenkbaren Konzepte bis hin zu Virtual Machine, irgendwie in so einer Maschine, die einfach nur wenige Bites hatte, komplett mit drin. Maximale Flexibilität. Aber dann natürlich auch eine unglaublich hohe Anforderung an Stabilität. Da kommen wir dann wieder so mit den Tests mit rein, weil in der Raumfahrt ist halt dieses geht irgendwann nicht mehr, geht nicht. Also die Scheiße muss einfach laufen. Und du kannst es einfach nicht verkacken. Ich meine, ich hab jetzt irgendwie vor sieben Jahren hab ich mit Raumzeiten Podcast gemacht über dieses Projekt Bibi Colombo. Der Ding ist jetzt gestartet. Das ist dann, das waren die sechs Jahre, glaube ich. Apollo Guidance Computer hieß er natürlich, klar. Also sechs Jahre ist das her. Jetzt ist das Ding gerade gestartet in Kuru. Ist jetzt sieben Jahre unterwegs. Und dann fangen die an, da irgendwie ihre Instrumente auszupacken. Klar, testen die vorher und so weiter. Aber wenn sie dann nicht funktionieren, wenn dann nicht alles klappt, dann ist irgendwie alles vorbei.
Ja, oder auch diese Kometen, wie heißt das noch gleich? Oder Asteroiden, diese ewig lange Rumpf. Wie hieß denn diese letzte Mission hier? War doch auch ESA?
Ja, die Landung auf dem Kometen.
Okay, aber es war ja auch...
Rosetta.
War ja auch so eine riesenkomplexe Mission.
Ja, also alle Weltraummissionen sind eigentlich so. Und diese Long Range Missionen sind natürlich nochmal besonders so. Ich hab halt einfach festgestellt, die Motivation in der Raumfahrt für diese Projekte. Die Leute, die an solchen Projekten arbeiten, mit Liebe ist das nicht ausreichend beschrieben. Also das ist mehr, ja. Exponenten muss man da noch dransetzen. Und eine extreme Akribie. Und so was, da auch die Motivation aufrechtzuerhalten, scheint ja auch schon vor 50 Jahren funktioniert zu haben.
Die fingern auch zum Mond und machen keine Werbe-Webseite für.
Also ich kann zum Beispiel bei diesem Wuger, mit diesen Duddle-Spielen, ja, also letztendlich, das Produkt hat mich vergleichsweise gering interessiert. Da war tatsächlich die Verantwortung zu haben für so ein Software mit so einer User-Base und solchen Anforderungen an die Stabilität. Also die technische Herausforderung hat mir da den großen Spaß und die Motivation gemacht und es war halt klar.
Man muss ja laufen, sonst kann man ja die kleinen Kinder nicht melken.
Genau, die Mütter von den kleinen Kindern, ne? Aber wenn nur... Ja, aber nichtsdestotrotz war halt die Ansage von unseren Chefs so, okay, wenn das Spiel jetzt eine halbe Stunde nicht läuft, verlieren wir so einen Stapel Geld. Ja, und dann hat man irgendwie schon so, okay, und ich hab jetzt hier alle Knöpfe in der Hand. Und es war spannend, hat irgendwie deutlich Spaß gemacht, da an so einem System zu schrauben und dafür verantwortlich zu sein und eben auch diese Verantwortung übertragen zu bekommen, zu haben. Und die Projekte, wo ich eigentlich nur so Coding Monkey bin und alles andere, also ich hab nur den Code zu schreiben, alles andere wird mir sozusagen abgenommen. Das sind die, wo ich am wenigsten Bock drauf hab.
Wäre man noch motivierter gewesen, wenn man Anteile am Unternehmensgewinn und Verlust hätte?
Ja, das ist...
Ein Prozent des Tages Umsatzes.
Naja, bei VUGA gab es so Mitarbeiteranteils, Dingsbombs, die sich natürlich jetzt am Ende nicht ausgezahlt haben, weil es dann am Ende doch nicht mehr so gut lieb. Also es geht ihnen aktuell wieder okay, aber nicht so kometenhafte Aufstiege, wie es aus den besten Dotcom-Bubble-Zeiten bekannt ist. Aber ehrlich gesagt, ja, weiß nicht.
Ich finde, das ist schon ein valider Punkt, weil mir geht das nämlich gerade nicht an. Ich sehe eher den Sinn darin, wenn ich weiß, wofür das ist. Ich habe vorher auch für eine Firma gearbeitet, die kleiner war, wo irgendwie klar war, wo es hingeht. Und jetzt in so einem noch großen Ding ist es halt so, wofür mache ich das? Welcher Sinn steht dahinter? Es wird irgendwann abgeschalten. Also man produziert so teilweise so ins Wissen, dass es irgendwie nicht weitergeht.
Aber Geld ist ein ganz schlechter Motivator generell.
Nein, nein, nein, wenn ich weiß, dass es meine Firma ist oder ich an dieser Firma irgendwie beteiligt bin, hat man noch eine ganz andere emotionale Bindung dazu. Und sieht vielleicht auch so, weil Huckel ja auch meinte, sich überlegt, wie er leben will, auch so viel so dieser Ansatz ist, wie will ich leben, was macht mir Spaß? Und wenn mir meine Arbeit keinen Spaß macht, fahre ich so ein Hobby, weil Koden war halt und ist immer noch so ein Hobby, was Spaß und Freude bringen sollte. Auch eine Menge Frustration immer mal wieder, aber das gehört echt dazu.
Genau, das könnte man jetzt nicht alleine durch Geld ersetzen oder durch Anteile.
Überhaupt nicht. Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Deswegen, also klar, es schadet jetzt auch nicht, dass eine Firma sagt, wenn wir Erfolg haben wirtschaftlich, dann geben wir auch was den Mitarbeitern zurück und irgendwie so anteile ich und so weiter. Da gibt es ja verschiedenste Modelle. Aber das wäre jetzt nicht mein primärer Motivationsgrund. Das wollte ich eigentlich auch nur zum Ausdruck bringen. Das ist eher so die Kirsche obendrauf noch.
Also, den meisten Projekten, wo ich jetzt mitgearbeitet habe, ist es eigentlich ja so, dass du eh eine gewisse Grundmotivation bei den Leuten hast. Und das schwingt sich ja auch dann in dem Team relativ schnell ein, wenn man sieht, dass man irgendwas produzieren kann oder dass da tatsächlich was Sichtbares rauskommt. Also, diese Motivation, wenn die nicht vom Team selber heraus eh schon da ist oder kommt, dann stimmt irgendwas innerhalb des Teams nicht, irgendwie mit der Aufgabe. Aber da wird, glaube ich, auch kein Scrum Master das irgendwie retten können.
Ja, ich war ja bei so einer Bank, in Anführungsstrichen mal. Und da war irgendwie die ganze Firma in so einem Doomsday-Modus so schon. Irgendwie alle keinen Spaß, alle irgendwie so das Ding so runtergeritten, weil wir müssen jetzt hier Deadline, Deadline, also diese Deadline-Karotte immer schön eng vor die Nase gespannt und so. Aber richtig Spaß hatte da keiner. Und jetzt so ein Jahr später habe ich mal auf LinkedIn geschaut, wie viele von den Leuten, die da was gewuppt haben, noch da sind. Fast niemand mehr. Deren ganzer Brain-Schmalz hat schon die Firma wieder verlassen in der Zwischenzeit. Und das wird es als Firma halt auch auf gar keinen Fall eigentlich. Deswegen sollte auch da von der Firma oder von der Firmenführung ja schon die Motivation da sein, die Mitarbeiter bei Laune zu halten.
Lässt sich schon einiges zu sagen.
Ja, und viel kritisieren.
Na dann wenden wir uns doch vielleicht mal ein paar weltlicheren Dingen zu.
Jetzt bin ich gespannt, was du aus dem Themenblumenstrauß herauspeckst.
Na ja, in gewisser Hinsicht würde ich doch nochmal kurz im digitalen Raum bleiben. Ich meine, im Falle lassen wir ja eigentlich sowieso nie, ne? Michaela.
So, ich dachte Alex ist...
Nee, ich wollte dich nochmal... Wir hatten das vorhin hier irgendwie vor der Sendung so. Und du bist ja, wir haben ja festgestellt, du bist ja so ein all digital girl. Du bist ja so komplett... Wie nennt man denn das?
Ich weiß es nicht, was du...
In der Wolke lebend.
Na ja, es gibt so diesen Begriff digital native, den fand ich schon... Wollte ich dir aber gerade auch gar nicht unterstellen. Also tatsächlich bin ich immer... Weil ich war ein bisschen ärgerlich, als der Begriff aufkam, weil ich dachte immer, ich bin digital native.
Dafür bist du ein bisschen zu alt.
Das finde ich ja nicht.
Ja, so eine Altersgrenze zu irgendwie alle, die nach 1980 geboren sind, als digital natives zu bezeichnen, ist halt echt schwierig.
Was ist denn die Definition? Definition ist, du bist mit deiner Jugend, mit diesem ganzen Digitalkram aufgewachsen, der war wirklich komplett selbstverständlich und du hast überhaupt gar nicht anders gelernt, als mit irgendwas damit umzugehen. Passt. Ja, so war das bei mir. War echt.
Wir wollten doch gerade von Michaela reden.
Ja, wollten wir. Ich wollte nur darauf hinaus, dass ich diesen Begriff digital native irgendwie komisch finde, weil ich halt immer beleidigt bin, wenn man mir den Quar Alters nicht zugesteht.
Wie gesagt, das ist ja...
Wenn den auch sonst keiner haben will, dann nehm ich den halt.
Du bist Digital Immigrant. Vor 1970.
Jetzt nicht mehr.
Podcaster mit digitalen Migrationen.
Wo tatsächlich 1980 die ältesten gebrützten...
Ohne Scheiß, ich bin ja Medienwissenschaftler, das ist ein medienwissenschaftlicher Begriff und ich mochte das Paradigma damals schon nicht.
Ich hatte, wie gesagt, mit 19, glaube ich, Internet.
Also später als ich.
Ja, später als alle anderen eigentlich.
War das da schon Internet, Tim, oder?
Internet? Na, ich hatte Internet...
Also jetzt per Definition so IP und so.
Wie jetzt Zuhause, Always On, oder was meinst du? Oder Berührung damit und irgendwie Kenntnis darum?
Berührung damit und Kenntnis darum.
Berührung damit und Kenntnis darum habe ich mit IP seit Ende 80er, Anfang 90er.
Ich hatte, glaube ich, 97, 98 Mode im Internet und so.
Also ich hab zumindest schon, ich hab, muss kurz mal überlegen, dass ich keinen Quatsch erzähle, aber ich habe 1990 und 91 Programmierer bei Siemens das beigebracht. Das war eine Berührung mit dem Thema.
Hier schreibt gerade jemand digitalen Neandertaler.
Homo digitalis. Also ich hatte da relativ frühe Berührungen, weil ich halt so diesen Mailbox, Modem, Geschichten und so weiter. Und dann bin ich ja irgendwie Clemens über den Weg gelaufen und so und der hat ja die ersten Pakete und Bits nach Berlin reingeholt und so. Und dann bin ich dann so ein bisschen in der Spur mit dem ganzen Kram in Berührung gekommen, bis dann wirklich mal IP in meinem Heim aufschlug, wie wir ja alle wissen, das dauert so. Aber ich hab Ende der 80er, 89 habe ich Usenit gehabt bei mir zu Hause. Das qualifiziert glaube ich jetzt schon mal ein bisschen als Internet. Aber ich wollte ja eigentlich gar nicht von mir reden, sondern mal...
Das war ein Versuch wert.
Ich wollte das jetzt auch nicht... Ich will das gar nicht schlecht machen oder abreden, um geht es mir überhaupt gar nicht. Sondern du bist aber dann quasi so um, wann, also um Jahrtausendwende sozusagen hart aufgeschlagen im Netz.
99. 2000, ja.
Dann ging es los. Und dann ging es ja auch irgendwie so ein bisschen los. Du bist sozusagen unbelastet...
2004. 2004.
2004.
So alt bin ich noch gar nicht. 2004.
Ja, egal, plus, minus ein, zwei, drei Jahre. Darum geht es ja nicht. Du bist sozusagen dann, also für deine Verhältnisse spät, aber dann trotzdem auch vermutlich relativ intensiv dann sozusagen damit in Kontakt gekommen und bist ja dann auch gleich verloren gewesen. Oder nicht?
Du meinst, ja, ich war gleich verloren, das stimmt.
Du warst gleich verloren, genau.
Einmal drin und sofort verloren.
Genau, und dann hast du aber auch sozusagen diesen ganzen Vorlauf so gar nicht gehabt. Und worauf ich hinaus will, ist, du gehst anders mit dem Netz um. Wir hatten ja so kleine Session heute und so. Du warst alles online, also so richtig online im Sinne von, es ist auch nicht unbedingt alles bei dir.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich wusste gerade nicht, was bei mir ist und was nicht. Es war egal. Wir haben ja dann gesehen, ich hab's auch bei mir.
Du hast den Kopf in der Cloud.
Und meine Dateien sind da drin. Wenn ich Dateien suche, dann suche ich die. Über den Browser. Der Browser ist sozusagen mein Standardinterface für alles, was ich habe. Ich hab meistens keine Apps, sondern Browser.
Das Internet ist für dich ein bisschen wie so ein unaufgeräumtes Kinderzimmer, wo du dann immer wieder graben gehst, wenn du was suchst.
Ja, das ist auch das Tolle eigentlich. Wir hatten vorhin Drive, deswegen habe ich Dateien gesucht im Google Drive. Ich glaube, das waren so eine der ersten, die dann auch OCR hatten. Das heißt, man konnte einfach alles reinpfeffern. Und es wird wieder gefunden. Man braucht eigentlich gar nicht so tiefe Ordnerstrukturen, wie ich sie da hatte für unsere Buchhaltung. Du findest auch so alles wieder. Pfefferst rein, findest wieder.
Macht es aber nicht nervös? Also, ich würde das nervös machen, wenn ich die Sachen nicht...
Ich ordne sie auch ein bisschen, aber...
Also, mal abgesehen davon, ne?
Ich suche dann meistens nicht über die Ordnerstruktur, sondern suche beim Drive oben über die Suche oder bei Fotos über die Suche. Wenn ich Fotos vom Surfen suche, dann suche ich nicht, wann war ich surfen und scrolle darunter, sondern gebe halt Surfing ein und dann finde ich mein...
Also mich macht das eigentlich immer schon irre, wenn ich nicht sofort, instantan ein Gefühl dafür habe, wo etwas ist.
Ich weiß ja, wo es ist.
Ich suche es dann zwar manchmal, weil es manchmal schneller über die Suche geht, da hinzukommen, aber so diese... die Struktur, die ich ausgelegt habe, dann halt idealerweise in so einem Dateipfad oder vielleicht auch mal in einer Datenbank, die will ich schon irgendwie im Griff behalten. So, aber eins von deinen Buddle-Tools ist ja Google Inbox. Das ist für dich, was dein Mail-Frontend ist.
Das stirbt doch jetzt.
Unter anderem stirbt Inbox scheinbar.
Sunsetted von Google.
Und ich verstehe es nicht, keine Ahnung. Google Mail ist so schlecht und alle, die ich kenne, die einmal Inbox aufhatten, sind für immer direkt dort geblieben.
Ach so, das ist was anderes als Google Mail.
Ja, das ist wie so ein Interface für Google Mail.
Das ist eher so aufgabenorientiert, würde ich sagen.
Du kannst Tas anlegen, oder E-Mail sind manchmal Tas. Du kannst zu E-Mails Tas dazuschreiben, und dann funktioniert eigentlich alles in meinem Prozess. Das war auch schon vorher bei Google Mail so, weil ich immer eine leere Inbox hatte und mir eigentlich immer nur Sachen für später zurückgestellt habe. Und auch nur wirklich das, was ich an einem Tag machen will, ist in der Inbox direkt drin und alles andere ist wegarchiviert. Und auch jetzt nicht mehr mit Tags oder so, weil man findet sie auch so wieder. Auch da keine ordentliche Hierarchie. Genau. Und deswegen war Inbox irgendwie perfekt. Das hatte alles, was ein Mail-Programm haben sollte, meiner Meinung nach. Oder hat es noch. Nur nicht mehr lang.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was ich dann mache.
Also ich kann Spark empfehlen als lokalen Client.
Aber ich mach doch keine App auf, wenn der Browser schon offen ist. Da noch 1000 Apps immer dazu aufzuhaben, ist halt egal.
Das schockiert mich. Ich sag das auch nochmal.
Und du hast dich auch total damit abgefunden, dass es halt Google ist und so, ne?
Ja, ich bin natürlich nicht zufrieden damit. Ich hab ja Google Business eigentlich für die meisten Sachen, deswegen zahle ich ja auch für Google. Aber natürlich bin ich nicht zufrieden damit, aber ich versuche mich einfach auf Google zu beschränken. Also ich hab keine anderen Sachen, außer jetzt Repos bei GitHub oder Bitbox.
Hast du dir auch den größten ausgesucht, da muss man sich dann auch nicht mehr.
Ja, da muss man auch nicht mehr was machen, außer sie stellen halt jetzt die Inbox ab. Das weiß ich noch nicht, was dann passiert.
Ok, also du lebst in Google?
Meine Sternchen auf der Google Maps, alles ist da. Ich weiß es nicht. Was ich dann mache in anderen, irgendwie weiß ich nicht. Zurück zu Gmail-Interface.
Wie sagte Peter Glaser mal so schön, die Welt ist eine Google. Also ich finde das irgendwie strange, weil ich, nochmal, ich verurteile das nicht, ich stelle nur fest, dass das so ist. Ich habe mich da natürlich ganz anders hinentwickelt, eine ganz andere Vergangenheit sozusagen, eine ganz andere Kultur, Historie, wie man überhaupt sagt. An Cloud war ja gar nicht zu denken, als ich angefangen habe, weil da ist nur Cloud. Allein die Idee eines Servers war ja schon irgendwie absurd. Und jetzt leben offenbar ja viele Leute so. Nicht, dass es jeder macht, aber es ist ja schon so ein Ding. Man lernt ja dann das Internet auch nur auf den Pfaden von Produktwegen. So wie Google das Netz sich denkt, denkst du da mit?
Ja, oder ich glaube auch, wenn man jetzt aufschlagen würde, was ich im Internet besuche, dann sind das meistens wirklich Web-Applikationen, mit denen ich irgendwas tue und ich gehe niemals auf Nachrichtenseiten oder so. Aber ich benutze das Internet eigentlich zum Arbeiten mit Web-Apps und gar nicht so für Nachlesen.
Weil du gar nicht nachliest?
Weil ich zum Beispiel im Internet keine Nachrichten über so was wie Spiegel oder Zeit lese.
Das ist auch eher deprimierend gerade.
Also nimmst du überhaupt noch?
Ich lese Blogartikel, die über...
Bundeskanzlerin.
Das meiste, was ich lese, lese ich über Artikel, die auf Twitter in Twitterlisten erscheinen oder die auf Twitter irgendwie zu kommen. Deswegen lese ich auch... Ich bin nicht immer im tagesaktuellen Geschehen.
Das ist auch beneidenswert.
Weil ja, meistens lese ich nur Sachen, die mich fachlich interessieren. Bei Google hat es sich halt mit der Zeit zu ergeben, das war das erste, was es gab, und plötzlich ist alles drin. Wie gesagt, wenn ich mal gucken will, wo ich auf den Kanaren essen war, dann habe ich meine Maps mit den Daten, wo ich unterwegs war. Oder die Sternchen, die ich gesetzt habe, und so, oder?
Es ist ja auch ungemein praktisch. In gewisser Hinsicht hat ja Google auch Antworten geliefert, die das Internet selber so gar nicht hat liefern können. Und teilweise auch noch ein bisschen eleganter, als andere das gemacht haben. Viele Leute sind ja auch immer so überrascht zum Beispiel auch von dem Erfolg von Facebook. Und mich hat das zum Beispiel überhaupt nicht überrascht. Nicht, dass ich jetzt Facebook von Anfang an so auf dem Radar hatte und das so hab kommen sehen, dass es alles andere vorbei macht. Aber so das, was Facebook bietet, hat gegenüber dem, was das Netz an sich geboten hat, war so viel, naja ich will es nicht besser sagen, ja doch für die Leute war es besser, weil es einfacher zu verstehen war. So eine Nachricht verschicken und so weiter ist da doch relativ straightforward. Man kann über das User-Interface fluchen, aber im Vergleich zu setz mal ein Mail-Programm auf, richte dir deinen Mail-Server ein, versuche einfach mal nur zu konfigurieren, dass dein Mail-Server mit deinem Provider redet, mit 30.000 Passwortern und konfigurieren sie ihr Verschlüsselungs-Algorithmus, um ihren SMTP-Server anzusprechen. Welche Verschlüsselung hätten sie denn gern? Das ist doch alles zum kurzem schlecht gewesen. Und deswegen ist es überholt worden. Ich frage mich, ob das Netz jetzt eigentlich noch eine Chance hat, aus sich heraus, irgendwann nochmal alles so zu Standarddiensten werden zu lassen, die nicht nur von einer Firma getragen werden oder ob wir sozusagen für immer in so einer Shopping-Mall gefangen sind, in der es sozusagen für jede Art Dienst genau einen Laden gibt. Du kaufst halt dein Papier bei McPaper und dann nimmst du deinen Burger bei McDonalds ein und bei Douglas das Parfüm.
Michaela kriegt ja alles bei Google.
Ja, aber es wäre natürlich schon schöner und auch für Google besser, wenn es Konkurrenz gibt. Da bin ich ja, wenn es Konkurrenz gäbe dafür, wäre es ja gut. Aber ich mache ja nicht Numbers auf, wenn ich die Google Spreadsheets benutzen kann.
Guck mal, da bin ich zum Beispiel genau anders. Ich mache doch nicht Google Spreadsheets auf, wenn ich Numbers benutze.
Das ist offen. Das ist immer offen. Ich muss nur den Browser öffnen und schon sind alle meine Software-Dinger offen.
Ich muss nur Numbers öffnen und das geht schon.
Es gibt ja Numbers jetzt auch in der Cloud.
Man muss ja in der Spotlightsuche suchen nach dem Dokument im Zweifelsfall.
Ja, aber tatsächlich finde ich ja die mittlerweile die Web-Implementierung der Office-Produkte von Apple gar nicht so schlecht. Ich benutze die jetzt... Also ich habe mir auf dem einen Rechner habe ich die gar nicht mehr installiert, sondern benutze die nur dann noch in der Cloud. Aber ich glaube, da kommen wir nicht mehr wieder zurück. Oder aus der Mall kommen wir jetzt nicht so schnell wieder zurück.
Ist das Problem die Mall oder ist das die Leute, die in der Mall sind? Also die Anbieter? Naja, das ist halt immer so eine Frage. Ich meine, wenn du mit einem wirtschaftlichen Interesse sowas betreibst, dann wirst du immer ein McPaper haben. Naja, es ist quasi so, dass überhaupt diesen Service anzubieten, musst du ja erstmal genügend Kapital oder sowas zusammen finden, um überhaupt einen solchen Dienst zu starten, um in Konkurrenz mit Google anzutreten.
Gut, ich weiß nicht, ob der McPaper vergleich so der allerbeste war. Ich ringe allerdings auch noch ein wenig mit den Definitionen, worüber ich, was mir eigentlich gerade selber so ein bisschen durch den Kopf durchschiebt. Aber vielleicht mal so mehr auf die Kommunikation runterzubrechen. Diese, nehmen wir zum Beispiel mal die Messenger. Das ist vielleicht das deutlichste Ding. Ich hab jetzt irgendwie auch so hier so meinen Kids irgendwie auch so eine brauchbare Digitalinfrastruktur. Die können Messenger-Nachrichten empfangen, die können aber auch E-Mail empfangen. Aber jetzt denen irgendwie so E-Mail schmackhaft zu machen und ihnen zu erklären, was da jetzt vielleicht der eigentliche Sinn dahinter ist, außer das ist das Ding, wo du eine Nachricht kriegst, wenn du dein Passwort ändern musst. Das scheint ja so Mail heutzutage im Wesentlichen zu sein.
Oder mit Behörden kommunizieren. Da bist du jetzt die nächsten 20 Jahre noch mit E-Mail über, bevor die einen WhatsApp-Account dir auf der Webseite sagen.
Da bin ich mir ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so sicher.
Das ist zumindest so die Wahrnehmung der jungen Menschen.
Finanzamt WhatsApp, oder?
Also das Ding ist halt, E-Mail ist halt noch Infrastruktur, die du selber betreiben kannst. Und ich glaube, das ist jetzt schon so, dass die Regierung, Verwaltung, wie auch immer, da noch...
Ja, wir sehen ja wie gut die...
Das ist das eine, aber da wird noch ein Wert drin gesehen, dass nicht irgendeinem US-Anbieter mit fragwürdigen AGBs einfach zu überlassen.
Ja, klar, natürlich ist das so. Nur trotzdem muss man auch sehen, E-Mail hat sich jetzt in den letzten 40 Jahren echt nicht verbessert. Und das ist ein Zeitraum, der ist lang.
Ich liebe E-Mail, das beste Protokoll von der Welt. Es hat irgendwie 4D-Karten überstanden oder noch mehr und es läuft immer noch. Es skaliert noch. Nee, doch?
Nein, klar. Was?
Wieso denn nicht?
Ja, es skaliert auch, ja.
Es skaliert auch.
Es skaliert aber ordentlich.
Das hab ich kein Problem mehr, seitdem ich...
Vor 20 Jahren hat Steve Bill Gates gemeint, mit Spam, das wär bald vorbei.
Aber ich hab mittlerweile jetzt kein Spam-Problem mehr.
Ja, du hast kein Spam mehr, weil du deinen Elitenserver hast. Handgebürste geschrubbt. Das ist so wie, ich hab kein Problem mit meinem alten Auto, weil halt jeden Tag mit der Zahnbürste den Auspuff wien hast. Und den Luxus erlaubt sich ja auch nicht unbedingt jetzt jeder. So und der Rest, also ich mein, ich hab auch irgendwie einen halbwegs brauchbaren Mail-Provider, aber trotzdem ist das irgendwie alles elend und schwierig, mal anders zu konfigurieren etc. Während halt so die Messenger Experience da ganz anders ist. Schnell definierte Fehlermeldungen, Retries etc. Und hier in dieser Mail-Welt musst du dir halt immer noch irgendwie kryptische Fehlermeldungen auf Russisch vorlesen lassen, weil du gar nicht weißt, warum du die jetzt kriegst. Also du hast doch nicht mal was getan und kriegst Fehlermeldungen. Also das ist ja alles vollkommen kaputt. Du sitzt schwammig vor diesem Netz und weißt überhaupt nicht, was es von dir will. Natürlich gibt es den Wunsch und den berechtigten Anspruch, dass das einfach ist. So, wenn wir jetzt mal als Internet 50 Jahre nach vorne denken, nicht so was kommt jetzt in den nächsten 10 Jahren, wo wir vielleicht irgendetwas gerne hätten, sondern wie fundamental wird sich die Netzkommunikation langfristig ändern, weil es geht ja nicht weg. Das Internet, das wissen wir ja. Das wird auch noch in 50 Jahren sein. Wenn es die Menschheit bis dahin noch schaffen, gibt es auch noch das Internet.
Der letzte Mailserver wird dann abgeschaltet in 50 Jahren.
Vielleicht können wir dann schon Sachen denken und die werden direkt versendet, aber immer noch als E-Mail?
Dein Kleinhörner hat ja eine Nachricht gesendet.
Ping!
Ich vermag das nicht abzuschätzen, was in 50 Jahren passiert. Gerade wird alles schlechter.
Ich kann auch nicht abschätzen, ich will jetzt nicht prophetisch sagen, in 50 Jahren wird das und das sein. Aber ist ja klar, dass das in 50 Jahren sich doch enorm abgerundet haben muss, was so Basisdienste betrifft. Also ich kann mir einfach nicht vorstellen, dass das in dieser Shopping-Mall-Situation verbleibt, sondern all diese Dinge, die man dann macht und dann wird man halt so in den nächsten 10, 20 Jahren wird sich so 90% der Standardnutzung irgendwie so weit herausgeschält haben, dass es dann auch irgendwann nicht mehr rentabel ist, das proprietär zu führen. Ja, das wäre vielleicht ein bisschen meine Hoffnung, aber es ist auch eher meine Erwartung. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es dauerhaft gelingt, diese Dinge wirklich so in privater Hand zu halten. Es muss universeller werden, wird sich standardisiert, analysieren muss interoperabel werden. Es wird so ein Basisnetz geben müssen, so ein Kerninternet, Dinge, die heute vielleicht noch außergewöhnlich sind, wie Michaela sucht in ihrem Fotowald und im Kontorauszug dickigt und so. Dass solche Vorgänge, normale Vorgänge des Lebens, der persönlichen Recherche, alle irgendwie standardisierte Grundfunktionen des Internets sind. Dass das so einen ganz dicken Crust unten kriegt, wo diese ganzen grundlegenden Dinge abgefeiert werden und quasi mitgeliefert werden.
Gibt es eigentlich diese Option, die Google hat, dieses Google-Business, gibt es eigentlich nicht von Apple, oder?
Naja, du kannst ja schon hier iCloud klicken.
Was meinst du denn genau mit Google-Business?
Diese Google-Business ist doch nochmal ein bisschen anders als das reine Google-Mail.
Du kannst deine eigenen Domänen drauf registrieren, zum Beispiel.
Da war noch ein bisschen was mehr. Ich krieg das nicht mehr alles zusammen, weil ich das jetzt auch letztens gelesen hab.
Ich muss mir das auch aktuell anschauen.
Ich hab's jetzt nicht verstanden.
Was ist jetzt Google Business? Google Business wurde explizit angeboten für Unternehmen, wenn du gerade am Gründen bist.
Warum alles selber machen.
Du hast halt deine Mail-Server, deine Dokumente, deinen Drive und deine Domänen. Und alles läuft dann über Google.
Genau, aber ich dachte, das wär noch ein bisschen mehr als nur Google Mail.
Na, alles Services, aber alles auch unter deiner Domäne vor allen Dingen. So war es zumindest bei VUGA, die haben das auch so gemacht.
Meint ihr Google My Business? Nee, das ist dieses Branchen verzeichnet. Ich bin mich jetzt gerade etwas verwirrt, was genau ihr eigentlich jetzt meint.
Aber trotzdem, die Antwort ist relativ schnell gegeben. Ich glaube, das ist bei Apple nichts der gleiche. Deren Interesse ist ja...
Hätte sein können, dass jetzt so häufig Freak Show gehört haben und so viele Sachen über Tims Buchhaltung gehört haben.
Ah, G-Suit heißt das jetzt.
Deshalb auch der Vortrag von Tim.
Ja genau, deswegen jetzt der Vortrag von Tim. Der wollte sich halt einfach nochmal bewerben.
Wo war's? Also der andere Tim wollte sich bewerben. Bei wem jetzt? Bei Google. Das Rundum-Sorglos-Paket. Ach, das ist doch schön.
Habt ihr, ich will nochmal quasi zurück auf den Punkt von Tim kommen, habt ihr gesehen, dass Tim Berners-Lee dieses Solid-Plattform, oder was auch immer das ist, vorgestellt hat? Weil ich glaube... Ich bin nur gerade draufgekommen, weil die Thematik da sehr nah dran ist. Ich glaube, das Problem ist weniger, dass du... Also das Problem ist wahrscheinlich die Infrastruktur, die wir haben. Und solange wir weiter mit dieser zentralisierten Struktur operieren, wirst du immer wieder in solche großen Player wie Google oder Facebook rein. Weil, wie gesagt, einfach die Einstiegshürde für mich jetzt zu hoch wäre, einen eigenen Messaging Service hochzuziehen. Solid ist Messaging? Nee, das ist glaube ich eher so eine Basis, wie man dezentralisiert. Also wahrscheinlich, ich hab jetzt auch nur die Nachrichtenberichte darüber gelesen und nicht die Plattformen an sich. Das wird wahrscheinlich irgendwas Dezentralisiertes sein. Und in dem Zusammenhang gibt's auch mittlerweile sehr lustige Initiativen wie Scuttlebutt. Ich weiß nicht, ob euch das was sagt.
Hab ich auch schon mal gehört, aber was ich jetzt nicht kann, krieg ich nicht zusammen definiert.
Das ist sowas, das geht komplett damit, lagerst du den gesamten Trafik eigentlich auf Peer-to-Peer-Netzwerke aus. Das heißt, wenn du sowas wie Facebook machen würdest, dann hat halt jeder, der jetzt an diesem Netzwerk teilnimmt, einmal eine Kopie von Facebook bei sich rumliegen. Und so hast du halt keine zentrale Entität, wo die Wahrheit ist, sondern du einigst dich halt auf irgendwas dazwischen und tauschst das aus.
So wie Newsgroups in den 80ern.
Ich sag dir, da dreht sich alles im Kreis. Innovationen gibt es nicht.
Soweit würde ich nicht gehen.
Ich schon.
Also nicht zu verwechseln mit einer Blockchain. Weil da wird jetzt nicht auf die Integrität des Stroms oder bzw. deiner Scuttlebutt Instanz wird jetzt nicht irgendwie noch ein Proof gemacht. Aber das ist ein ganzes Netzwerk, das wir jetzt noch nicht so gut kennenlernen können. Stille im Podcast, das ist sehr gut, hab ich gehört.
Ja, alle sind so ganz so überfordert von dem Thema und der Gedragweite.
Das ist ja auch ein ganz kleines Thema, das hat man mal schnell durch exerziert.
Ich schätze das, wenn man die Zukunft des Internets diskutiert, klar.
Einer muss das ja machen.
Also ich hätte das bei mir auch lieber anders, aber es ist so gewachsen.
Die Tims sind zuständig für die Zukunft.
Also aus meiner Sicht wird das einfach nur noch krasser mit diesem Konsumverhalten, dass es mehr und mehr sozusagen so ein Fernseh-Shopping-Window-Konsum-Netzwerk wird und keiner mehr weiß, wie es eigentlich funktioniert und keiner auch wirklich so dann dementsprechend das Interesse hat, daran mitzuwirken, sondern einfach nur noch so, ja, hier, komm, Jepä, Messenger gratis, super! Fragen, warum ist der gratis? Wie kann das sein, dass so was wie ein Messenger gratis ist, der auch eine horrende Infrastruktur braucht? Ist mir egal, ich will ein Message schreiben.
Irgendjemand wird den thermonuclearen Krieg ja auch überleben und dann wollen sie es wieder zusammen machen.
Schön, dass ich gerade hier Huxleys Schöne neue Welt gelesen habe und den futurologischen Kongress gerade.
Ja, also ich bin da gerade nicht so auf der totalen hoffnungsvollen Rewelle auf jeden Fall.
Ach, ich finde es jetzt ein guter Zeitpunkt, irgendwie neuen Optimismus zu entwickeln.
Ich weiß nicht, wie soll es denn weniger proprietär plötzlich werden? Die Tendenz ist ja einfach genau die andere Richtung.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, es gibt nichts proprietäres mehr, es ist nur die Basis des Netzes, die Grunddienste, das Kommunizieren miteinander. Also heute haben wir zehn verschiedene Messenger, die die Leute benutzen und sind vollkommen voneinander abgeschnitten. Das funktioniert nicht wie das Telefonnetz, das Postnetz, etc. Das ist langfristig kein haltbarer Zustand. Der ist aber derzeit, weil sich das nicht finanziell und technisch auch nicht sozusagen auf einer Standardisierungsbasis leisten lässt, auch aus politischen Gründen, ist das halt nicht so. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das so bleiben wird. Ich denke, dass irgendwann dieses Nachrichten versenden, egal wie viel tolle Features du da jetzt noch draufflanscht, wird irgendwann genug sein. Dann ist definiert, was man so braucht. Und das wird sich dann quasi abtrennen in ein Kerninternet und wird da ein Grundbasisdienst werden, den das Netz einfach von sich heraus leistet. Derzeit ist unser Internet im Prinzip immer noch dieses Verständnis von, naja, Internet ist, wenn ein Rechner einem anderen Rechner ein Paket senden kann. Ein künftiges Internet wird mehr sein als das. Da ist eine viel dickere, im Idealfall, kropografisch etc. ausreichend abgesicherte Grundebene, die diese ganzen Dienste eingebaut hat, die sozusagen da automatisch durchgeführt werden. So wie ein IP-Paket einfach weitergeleitet wird, wird auch eine Nachricht weitergeleitet werden.
Ja, das klingt traumhaft. Aber die Standards müssen entwickelt und dann ja auch implementiert werden. Und heutzutage entwickeln, weiß nicht, zum Beispiel Apple, machen die jetzt so an Standardentwicklung mit und übernehmen Sachen von anderen. Also die Tendenz sehe ich halt überhaupt nicht. Eher die andere Richtung. Jeder macht seinen eigenen Standard.
Das ist eine gute Brücke zu Open Source Development. Ja, genau. Und zwar wollte ich mal meine Erfahrung damit teilen, weil ich das jetzt schon seit, boah, es werden bald zwei Jahre, bald zwei Jahre mache. Und da wir vorhin schon die Diskussion so ein bisschen gehabt haben, wie man das organisiert oder sowas, sondern eigentlich, es gibt ja da kein richtiges finanzielles Interesse daran und so pure oder quasi so wie man in Open Source denkt, es ist ja eigentlich so, dass man, man möchte etwas, ich weiß nicht, ob es etwas Gutes ist, aber man möchte irgendwie, dass Leute einen mehr nutzen von der Software haben, die man da entwickelt. Und da gibt es halt viele Dynamiken während des Open Source Entwicklungs, die teilweise positiv sind und die teilweise auch nicht so positiv sind. Zum Beispiel einen, um mit den nicht so positiven anzufangen, die Open Source Community hat einen sehr ruden oder rüden Umgangston untereinander. Das ist in der Podcast-Serie oder Welt gar nicht so krass tatsächlich. Das ist eigentlich sehr flauschig und nett und ab und zu kommt halt mal ein Idiot vorbei und poltert ein bisschen, aber der wird dann meistens auch, man weiß, wie man diejenigen dann...
Hast du Tim gerade ein Idiot genannt?
Nein. Der macht das subtiler. Aber so generell ist es halt eigentlich eher so, dass man, und das merkt man auch bei größeren Projekten, so dass man tatsächlich auch oft richtig hart einstecken muss, wenn man da aktiv ist. Also zumindest ist es mir immer so bei meinen Exkursionen, wenn ich irgendwie mal bei einem Framework an die Grenze gekommen bin und da reingepiekt habe und dann mal quasi ein Podcast oder was aufgemacht haben, dann ist da auch schon öfter der Strahl mir entgegengekommen. Und das ist halt interessant, warum das so ist. Und ich glaube, Michaela hat auch schon ähnliche Erfahrungen gemacht, oder?
Du erinnerst mich immer an Ian Wu, von der Wu gemacht hat. Und der hatte eben, ich hab's grad Tim in Slack gepostet, so einen tollen Talk über seine Open Source Journey und auch, was er alles einstecken muss gehalten. Das war ein ganz toller Talk. Die haben leider keine Videoaufnahme, aber ja.
Wieso postest du mir das in Slack?
Ich bin in diesem anderen nicht.
Warum nicht?
Weiß ich nicht, genau.
Hast du schon genug Slacks, oder was?
Auch weil ich nicht hinzugefügt hab.
Na komm zu uns, komm, ist schön da.
Aber auch das ist eine Sache, die sich gefühlt in den letzten 20 Jahren nicht groß geändert hat, weil auch als ich das erste Mal in irgendwelchen Irk-Channels hier und da mal eine Frage oder so hatte, das ist das Gleiche wie heutzutage exakt. Und es gibt so immer so ein paar positive Ausnahmebeispiele, wo sich irgendwie die Leute schon von vornherein irgendwie entsprechend verhalten haben und so ein quasi Vorbild gegeben haben. Aber es gibt auch genauso gut aus der Neuzeit junge Leute, die wieder genau den gleichen Scheiß machen.
Ja, weil sich viele immer dadurch so angegriffen fühlen, wenn du irgendwie vielleicht wirklich einfach nur eine Verbesserungsvorschlag hast und die denken halt so, du würdest dir damit persönlich angreifen.
Das ist ein generelles Problem.
Dieses gemeinschaftliche an etwas arbeiten, also ich weiß nicht, es kommt mir halt auch in einigen Teilen so reingesellschaftlich so als nice Utopie vor. Also es funktioniert vielleicht in einigen Sachen ganz gut, aber ich weiß nicht, dadurch, dass du auf so viele eigenartige Charaktere teilweise stößt.
Aber das ist prinzipiell sowieso Gift für jedes Projekt, wenn du Leute hast, die nicht oder die jede Kritik persönlich nehmen, auch wenn sie eigentlich das haben. Das ist in realer Zusammensetzung wie auch natürlich besonders virtuell ganz, ganz schlecht. Und davon gibt es auf jeden Fall viel zu viele Leute.
Was auch geil ist, wenn du an irgendwelchen Sachen mal kurz arbeitest und dann den Leuten sagst, hier folgen, das geht nicht, weil die und die Gründe, die schicken dir dann ein Pull-Request auf was, den hast du gerade erklärt, warum es nicht funktioniert, lösen das so, wie sie dir es gepitcht haben, und du denkst dir so, hast du eigentlich zugehört? Und man dann hier, ich hab dir das jetzt total schnell mal verbessert, weil du hast eben nicht zugehört, das ist genau eben nicht die Lösung.
Ja, ich meine, das ist, also ja, ich würde auch sagen, das überwiegende Problem ist das jetzt eben Beschriebene, der andere Teil der Medaille oder die andere Seite, die aber ein bisschen kleiner ist, komischerweise ist es ein kleines Paradox, aber die andere Seite ist kleiner, der Medaille. Genau, ist halt auch, was ich auch oft in so Projekten sehe, dass halt die Leute dann auch irgendwie die dusseligsten Issues oder Pull-Requests feilen, ohne halt wirklich mal sich hier hinzusetzen und zumindest irgendwie im Moment versuchen zu verstehen, was da eigentlich ist, sondern irgendwie, ich hab hier gesagt, im Rhythmus steht Make und Compile und dann erwarte ich, dass das jetzt funktioniert und jetzt kriege ich aber eine Fehlermeldung, Issue, ohne auch nur überhaupt die Fehlermeldung zu lesen, was da steht, die direkt schon den Hinweis, vielleicht auch das eigene Fehlverhalten oder so hat. Das kann, das erklärt halt so einen kleinen Teil davon, dass bestimmte Projekte vielleicht oder die Maintainer davon auch dann massiv generbt sind und dann auch vielleicht legitime Requests so ein bisschen abwatschen, aber das ist wie gesagt nur ein kleiner Teil, den ich da vielleicht noch so ein bisschen anrechnen möchte, weil ich erlebe das auch bei mir relativ oft, wenn ich so mit Open-Source-Software arbeite und natürlich funktioniert da nicht so immer alles so auspacken, auf den Knopf drücken, fertig. Hatte ich ja glaube ich letztes Mal erzählt, oder vor einer Weile, wo ich diese Navigationssoftware, diese Open-Source-Navigation-Software sehen und ein Plugin, und es kompilte nicht und es ging alles nicht. Und dann habe ich auch direkt erstmal irgendwie so ein Issue gefilert, weil ich dachte, okay, das müsste jetzt schon gehen, so wie es auf der Webseite steht. Und dann halt doch Stack Traces gelesen und selber hingefummelt. Und ich hab's zum Laufen gekriegt und es ist schon so, dass am Ende der Issue immer noch berechtigt ist, aber ich hab dann zumindest mal dem Maintainer schon eine gewisse Arbeit einfach schon vorweggenommen und gleich auch sozusagen die Legitimierung mit übernommen. Und nicht jetzt sozusagen einfach nur geht nicht, hier finde ich selber raus, wieso? Löse mein Problem!
Ich hatte das irgendwie auch. Ich weiß gar nicht in welchem Projekt, dass ich halt irgendwie irgendein Security-Projekt, was ich eingesetzt hatte. Und auch halt irgendwie nicht compiled, keine Ahnung. Und dann hat halt einfach nur ein Package gefehlt. Und bin halt auch einfach mal eine Stunde durch den Stack gewuselt, bis ich dann halt rausgefunden hab, was da wirklich fehlt. Und ich war dann halt auch so, schreibst du da jetzt irgendwie ein Issue? Und dann aber nochmal nachgeguckt, ob das wirklich nicht drin steht in der Package-JSON, glaube ich am Ende. Dann waren die halt auch so, oh Gott, sorry, sorry. Einfach nur, weil man es mal vergessen hat. Weil es kann ja auch passieren, weil du irgendwas mal nur schnell installiert hast und nicht wie zum Beispiel ein Minus Minus Safe oder was du da dahinter setzt, damit du es wieder in der Package-JSON hast. Kann ja immer mal passieren.
Der Talk ist leider nicht online, weil die die Aufnahmen versaut haben, habe ich gerade gesehen. Aber eine Sache zum Beispiel, du kannst ja ein paar Maßnahmen ergreifen, zum Beispiel, ich glaube, das hast du schon gemacht auf GitHub, dass du so eine Vorstruktur zum Beispiel für Issues hast.
Nee, habe ich nicht, der Publisher hat das, das könnte man machen, ja.
Und was ihm auch, glaube ich, stark geholfen hat, ist einfach am Anfang in dieser Template auch zu sagen, hier ist unser Stack Overflow. Wenn du Probleme mit dem Tool hast und gar nicht jetzt irgendwie einen Feature Request oder einen Bug Report und so weiter hast, geh zu Stack Overflow, wir haben den Tag, wir kümmern uns dort darum, sodass eben das alles aus dieser Github-Kommunikation, wo du halt, er meinte das größte Problem für ihn wäre gewesen, das ist morgens sein Anlaufding, nicht wie Inbox bei mir, sondern er geht halt ein und es deprimiert halt direkt, wenn man morgens direkt angeschissen wird. Das funktioniert noch nicht von fremden Menschen. Und deswegen wollte er das da eben auch alles raushaben und gerade auf Github alles sauber und möglichst motivierend und nicht demotivierend. Das könnten so zwei Ansätze sein. Irgendwie haben wir was auf Stack Overflow, Podloft, Tag oder so, das könnte man ja...
Nee, also hauptsächlich ist es ja so, dass die Implementierer... Also es gibt jetzt nicht so viele Implementierer wie Nutzer. Also bei der Publisher ist es recht einfach zu installieren, zu verwenden. Aber der Aufwand, das du selber entwickeln musst, ist ja beim Publisher jetzt nicht so ergeben. Vielleicht die Templates, das wäre so ein Ansatz.
Was meinst du mit der Aufwand, also die Notwendigkeit?
Na ja, meine Stack Overflow wird ja meistens dafür verwendet, um nicht deine Alltagsprobleme zu lösen, wie du jetzt gerade einen Podcast publishst, sondern wie du eine bestimmte Software integrierst oder verwendest.
Ja, vielleicht könnte man sich auch nochmal was anderes nehmen. Ich habe auch bei anderen Software so mal Jitter gehabt. Die hatten halt einfach einen Text.
Wir haben ja die Community, das geht ja eigentlich auch ziemlich fluffig. Manchmal sind die, also ich versuche meistens immer ziemlich zügig zu antworten. Das klappt nicht immer, aber ich bin ja am liebsten, wenn Leute dann tatsächlich gleich mit einem Pull-Request um die Ecke kommen. Hier ist dein Problem und hier ist übrigens die Lösung. Meistens ist es leider dann so, dass die CI ihn dann um die Ohren haut, weil an irgendeiner Stelle halt irgendeine bestimmte Formatien nicht und wenn es auch nur eine ganz kleine Formatien ist, nicht eingehalten wurde. Sodass es dann aber quasi diese Reaktivierung der Leute, die den Pull-Request festgestellt haben, echt schwer ist. Ich habe es jetzt oft gehabt, oder es sind zwei Pull-Request zum Beispiel gerade offen, wo nur eine ganz kleine Kleinigkeit da ist, wo ich sagen würde, na klar, machen wir. Ich schreibe es auch drunter, du musst nur noch das machen, dann integriert dir das auch sofort. Aber das passiert dann nicht, weil dann appt auf einmal die Kommunikation ab und die sind dann weiter offen. Und das ist halt schade. Das hat irgendwie sowas auch so, das ist vielleicht die Überleitung, damit zu tun, wie motiviert man Leute permanent an einer Open-Source-Software zu kontributen. Das ist glaube ich eine Frage, die man...
Wie ich mir schon oft gestellt habe, ja. Wie macht man das?
Wir wissen es nicht.
Also wenn man das vielleicht richtig implementiert, brauchen wir ja nicht mehr dran weiterarbeiten.
So rein nach dem Wasserfall.
Also ich habe Erik am Anfang gesagt, dass ihn alle liebhaben werden. So ist es auch gekommen, wenn er das macht. Ich weiß nicht, ob das letztlich der aussagegebende Faktor gewesen ist, aber ich denke, ein Open Source Projekt muss auf jeden Fall in technischer, aber eben auch auf einer emotionalen Ebene rewarding sein. Es geht um Belohnungsmomente. Und diese Belohnung kann halt auf der einen Seite eine technische Belohnung, also was habe ich dabei gelernt, was habe ich geschafft, was war für mich möglich, Hürden, die man genommen hat, das ist ganz klar. Der eine Teil, es gibt auch so Entwickler, bei denen ist das dann auch der einzige Teil und die kümmern sich dann auch nicht so sehr darum, wie es dann zu benutzen ist zum Beispiel, weil ich es dann immer ein bisschen schade finde, wenn ich das auch verstehen kann, dass es nicht unbedingt jetzt jedem so liegt. Ja, ist ja auch okay, wenn man Dinge nur macht, um so eine technische Herausforderung zu bewältigen. Und dann kann es aber eben und sollte es eben auch eine Belohnung geben, in Form von glücklichen Menschen, die das nutzen. Es ist immer ein bisschen schwierig, so eine Situation herzustellen, in der das Glück dieser Leute, was dann eintritt, sich auch offenbart und einem auch ankommt. Das ist ja nochmal eine andere Frage, da kann man aber auch ein bisschen drum herum organisieren, denke ich. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall auch ein wichtiger Faktor, als ich so für die Idee von Potluff getrommelt habe, konnte ich halt schon relativ selbstbewusst sagen, naja, ich weiß, dass das eine vergleichsweise intelligente, aufgeschlossene und feinfühlige Szene ist, weil Leute, die halt gerne Wissen vermitteln, besprechen, reden, zwar da so eine gründkommunikative Ader ja ohnehin schon haben, sonst würden sie das nicht machen, sind da eben an der Stelle auch sehr empfänglich. Das hat man vielleicht nicht in allen Open Source-Projekten, aber hier war das auf jeden Fall der Fall und von daher eben auch ein wichtiger Faktor. So kam es ja dann auch. Letztendlich gab es da viel Feedback und gibt da eine gewisse Dankbarkeit. Es ist ein bisschen schwieriger, die jetzt in so eine finanzielle Support zu überführen, aber das ist ja dann eh immer noch eine andere Dimension. Ich denke, das sollte man eigentlich dann auch, wenn man so was macht, dann muss man halt auch gleich mitdenken, dass man eben auch so einen Service betreibt. Wir hätten ja auch von vornherein sagen können, okay, wir machen jetzt nicht nur eine Hosting-Software, sondern wir machen die auch gleich so, dass man damit auch einen Hosting-Dienst machen kann und dass man so einen Podcast-Provider aufbringt. Hatten aber alle irgendwie keinen Bock drauf und das auch, was wir technisch angestrebt haben, hätte dafür ja nicht getaugt. Aber wäre auf jeden Fall auch ein Ansatz gewesen. Ich finde, das kann aber so auch schon reichen. Man muss halt immer schauen, so wie viel Zeit hat man ein größeres Problem und ein anderer Reward-Strang an der Stelle ist natürlich auch, wie sehr gelingt es dann, neue Entwickler dazu zu gewinnen. Also wie kann man so ein Team wachsen lassen und Leute spüren lassen. Jetzt hatten wir ja zum Beispiel, dies Jahr ist aus meiner Perspektive auch nicht so gut gelaufen. Da muss man nochmal dran arbeiten, so dass wir aber Aufruf gemacht haben, wir wollen irgendwie eine neue Podler-Version, NG, machen wollen wir ja auch immer noch, wird auch im Prinzip dran gearbeitet, aber im Sommer ist so ein bisschen der Fokus gerade ein bisschen verloren gegangen, aus vielen Gründen, der wird aber auch wiederkommen. Und man hätte jetzt hier wahrscheinlich sehr viel mehr den Scrum Master geben müssen und sozusagen noch mehr dafür sorgen, dass da ein Lagerfeuer brennt, um den man sich halt auch herum versammeln kann. Da ist dann manchmal auch Treffen ganz hilfreich, dann ist das Subscribe ausgefallen, all diese ganzen Sachen, die ja dazu beigetragen haben. Das muss man an der Stelle auch gleich nochmal erwähnen. So Veranstaltungen zu machen, Treffen zu machen, Konferenzen zu machen, da dann halt auch User zusammenzubringen usw., das hilft halt extrem. Und jetzt, wo es aus organisatorischen Gründen mal nicht gelungen ist, zwei dieser Veranstaltungen, die ja eigentlich alle sechs Monate stattfinden sollen, hintereinander nicht zu machen, reißt da auch schon was ab. Es muss wieder gekittet werden, es wird auch wieder gekittet werden. Im März geht es ja auch weiter mit der Subscribe und dann hoffe ich, dass auch wieder dein Fluss kommt. Das ist das, was ich bisher immer gespürt habe. Schwierig ist es immer, wenn es um Finanzierungsfragen geht. Da hilft es nicht, wenn man nur ein bisschen macht. Da muss man entweder in die Vollen gehen oder es komplett sein lassen.
Ich habe jetzt gerade akut, dass wir für die einzelnen Projekte immer so eine Hauptentwicklerfigur haben. Das Problem ist leider, was passiert, wenn diese Person keine Zeit mehr hat, das zu machen? Wird vom Laster getroffen oder so? Dann ist es scheiße. Das sollte man ja versuchen zu vermeiden. Ich habe so ein bisschen auch das Gefühl, dass wir dann, wenn ich von wir spreche, dann meine ich mich. Das königliche Wir. Dass man da auch selber daran schuld ist. Weil man ja natürlich sein eigenes Königreich dann aufzieht und das hegt und pflegt. Aber so richtig irgendwie das auch von nach außen hinweg isoliert. Und so den Eindruck erscheinen lässt, dass das jetzt schon alles in Ordnung ist und dass man hier auch keine Hilfe braucht. Dann gehen sie bitte weiter. Das möchtest du einen Hilferuf absetzen. Ich möchte keinen Hilferuf, aber ich hätte es halt gerne, dass man so viel, was man, oder eines der Knackpunkte bei Softwareentwicklung und das man lernt, ist der Austausch mit anderen Entwicklern. Das ist maßgeblich. Und das findet halt zum Beispiel bei den Webplayer gerade nicht so richtig statt, weil ich weiß, wie ich das entwickle, ich schaue das da so rein. Und da gibt es halt kein Review, weil ich drücke dann halt selber den Merch-Button. Ob das richtig oder falsch ist, das weiß ich nicht. Also nach meinem Ermessen ist das richtig, aber wahrscheinlich habe ich auch einige Schnitzer da drinnen, die mir so persönlich nicht auffallen.
Ist aber auch echt schwierig, wenn man halt dazukommt. Also ich habe mir jetzt auch den Player angeschaut und habe halt eine Sache gesehen, das sieht klein genug aus, als würde ich dich mal anhauen können nach dem Motto, das würde ich ganz gern fixen. Und dann dachte ich mir, du musst dich dann eigentlich komplett da reinfuchsen und dann hat man so diese Bedenken, kann ich das überhaupt oder mache ich dann irgendwas kaputt?
Das geht ja gar nicht, da macht die CI ja vorher Schlossensachen. Nee, so nicht.
Und wenn man fünfmal in der CI gescheitert ist, ist man einfach gebannt.
Aber ich fand es schön zum Beispiel, dass du diese Help Wanted Labels hast. Ja, das finde ich ist halt sehr wenige und das ist auch ein Feature, was total gut ist.
Wir haben die Design Needed Flex überwiegend, die Help Wanted Flex.
Was auch cool ist, ist hier, gerade weil ja Hektober ist, dass halt viele dann so gemacht haben hier First-Isch oder First-Commit-Pull-Request, dass man halt weiß, okay, das ist was super Leichtes, oder super Leichtes in Anführungszeichen, wo man vielleicht einfacher reinkommt.
Ja, die gab es auch, da sind gerade nicht mehr so viele da. Das war auch eine ganz schöne Erfahrung, dass die Fanboys, Referenz auf andere Podcasts, verwenden jetzt auch den Webplayer, was ich sehr schön finde, und das hat hauptsächlich Dominik gemacht. Der hat auch schon zum Beispiel die Chapterbilder und die Chapterlinks, das waren auch so Sachen, da muss man sich schon ein bisschen reinfuchsen, um das zu machen. Aber ich hab halt einfach nicht die Zeit dafür gefunden, das hat er gemacht, das wollte er, weil die das Feature verwenden, hat er reingebaut und ist jetzt drinne. Und das fand ich schon eine sehr schöne Erfahrung. Vielleicht muss man da mehr einfacherer Tickets.
Oder aber vielleicht auch sowas zu nutzen, du wirst ja mit Sicherheit auch auf dem Kongress sein. Das ist ja leider nicht.
Umzug wahrscheinlich.
Sollen wir dir helfen?
Brauchst du ein Lastenrad?
Wir finden bestimmt zwei oder drei.
Bei Brenovir, das wäre echt ganz lustig.
Wer zieht denn zum Kongress um?
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich dämlich.
Abblasen, verschieben.
Den Kongress. 15.000.
Da reden wir gleich noch mal drüber. So geht das ja nicht.
Richtig.
Das ist eigentlich auch sonst eine total gute Idee, sich mal in Person zu setzen.
Mehr Workshop-artig oder?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es ein Workshop sein muss. Einfach, dass man sagt, ich hab halt Bock dran zu arbeiten. Geekend, ja, dass man einfach mal so sagen kann, hast du mal Zeit. Also ich mein, geht natürlich eigentlich auch nur dann, wenn man irgendwie irgendwo in der Nähe ist oder mal hinfahren kann. Aber dann wird einem vielleicht auch so die Angst genommen. Also weiß man halt irgendwie so, ja, was einen erwartet, wer dann halt auch so dran arbeitet. Also deswegen hätte ich jetzt so, Kongress war jetzt so mein erster Gedanke, dass so eine Veranstaltung generell...
Kleinerer Hackathon. Deswegen war das Video Subscribe auch so schade, weil erstens, gut, früher war es sowieso noch eigentlich ein bisschen cooler, als die Developer nicht nur so ein Track waren, sondern die gesamte Konferenz, aber zum Beispiel dein Talk dann in München über die Redux-Architektur und so. Genau, sowas braucht man vielleicht manchmal, wenn man in so ein Riesen-Repo erst mal reinlösen wird und sich nicht zwei Seiten Readme durchlesen will und alles.
Haben wir gar nicht so viel, aber ja.
Und vielleicht auch von einem anderen Framework jetzt zum Beispiel kommt, dass man so ein bisschen weiß, ah ja, okay, das ist so hier, wie ich es jetzt sozusagen so kenne, dass man ja...
Und sich dann danach an Issues setzt und auch sagt, okay, für das Hackathon-Wochenende oder das Subscribe-Wochenende oder das Kongress-Wochenende habe ich jetzt die und die Issues irgendwie gedacht. Ich bin zwei Stunden am Tag hier, spreche mich da an, außerdem gebe ich noch die und die Einführung und so versuche ich vielleicht persönlich weiter Verantwortung abzugeben, nicht Kompetenz.
Müssen wir mal gucken, mehr Designs wären gut.
Und so einen Entwicklungs-Track auf der Subscribe. Da könnte auch dieses ganze UX-Design und so mit rein.
Das ist UX-Klimbim. Gerödel, gebimsel, gediesel.
Sven erzählt, auch diese Sachen sind ja oft für diese Inhaltsersteller, die es jetzt heute gibt, gar nicht mehr so wichtig, die sehr getrennt sind von den Leuten, die das dann vernageln.
Ein Developer-Track wäre vielleicht mal ganz cool. Ich meine, wir hatten ja immer schon so ein bisschen die Coexistenz und Sachen wurden vorgestellt. Wir hatten mal so eine Zweiteilung versucht, dass wir mal so einen Pod-Love-Day da vorgemacht haben, so einen halben Tag. Das war aber eigentlich nicht so eine gute Idee. Es hat irgendwie nicht so richtig gepasst, aber wenn man es halt wirklich mal als Track denkt, dann mag das vielleicht besser Frucht.
Kann ja auch halb-halb sein, weil man will ja noch ein bisschen coden oder so, aber auch ein bisschen drüber erzählen.
Weißt du, also der Pod-Love-Webplayer sozusagen der einzige Teil, den du als Erfahrung, als größere Erfahrung hast, dann im Open-Source-Bereich?
Also so große, artige Contributions. Man muss auch sagen, der frisst auch viel Zeit. Viel anderes an Open-Source-Entwicklung schaffe ich jetzt gerade nicht währenddessen. Aber ja, das ist eigentlich so das Hauptding. Braucht man eine Erfahrung.
Und es ist dann wahrscheinlich niemand, der dich anpumpt, wenn du ein Pull-Request schickst?
Nein, außer die CI nicht.
Tja, ich mache ja immer nur so ganz kleine Sachen, die gar keine CI oder sonstiges benötigen. Ne, zum Beispiel hier mein eines kleines Shell-Skript, mein T-Marks-Rapper. Für ein Shell-Skript da setze ich jetzt nicht ein CI auf.
Hast du keine Tests für dein Shell-Skript geschrieben?
Aber da kommen die Leute auch immer von alleine mit ihren Pull-Request und bieten dann auch irgendwelche Features an. Und das andere, was noch einigermaßen erfolgreich war, was auch nicht getestet ist, was aber auch nicht testbar ist, ist mein Colorscheme. Wobei, das müsste ich jetzt eigentlich mal updaten so langsam, weil die meisten Editoren, die ich das mal gebaut hab, gar nicht mehr so aktuell sind. Ich glaube, es funktioniert jetzt vor allen Dingen noch Wim. Aber es bedanken sich immer noch Leute dafür und finden es toll. Aber das sind dann auch so Leute, die mir mein Wim-Colorscheme fixen, das finde ich super. Aber es sind so schöne kleine Sachen. Deswegen ist meine eigene Open-Source-Erfahrung immer total super. Ich mach einfach so mini kleine Futzeltools. Kann sich jeder relativ schnell einarbeiten. Man braucht kein großes Setup.
Na im Rahmen von den Players sind ja auch so weitere kleinere Source-Dinger noch mit entstanden. Aber die ich halt hauptsächlich weil der Player halt genau diese Anforderungen hatte.
Aber das ist natürlich auch der Klassiker dann in der Software-Entwicklung und generell so Modularisierung, dass man dann irgendwie nicht einen großen Monolithen hat, sondern so bestimmte Teilprobleme wieder in eigene Projekte auslagert, damit das dann alles noch ein bisschen greifbar bleibt.
Wollen wir mal voranschreiten thematisch?
Was würdest du denn für ein Thema machen?
Ich wollte einen Besuchsbericht von einer Veranstaltung geben, die wir ja auch schon angesprochen hatten im Vorfeld, nämlich das Vintage Computing Festival Berlin. Das ja immer wieder ganz charming ist. Und was sich in diesem Jahr schön gepaart hat mit meiner aktuellen Begeisterung für nachgebaute CPUs. Freak Show berichtete, wir hatten ja ja schon diverse Exkurse, sowohl den Exkurs da nach Cambridge und davor unsere Einblicke in die frühe Kryptographie im Bletchley Park und so weiter und dass es halt viele interessante Projekte gibt. Jetzt war ich auf diesem Vintage Computing Festival und da habe ich dann zunächst einmal ein Projekt, was ich letztes Jahr, oder was vorletztes Jahr schon hier in der Freak Show schon mal angesprochen hatte. Das ist hier bei der, hoffentlich sage ich jetzt nichts Falsches, TU Berlin Elektrotechnik Studiengang. Da haben die so eine CPU nachgebaut oder nicht nachgebaut, sondern eine CPU gebaut mit der Idee, halt einen richtigen 32-Bit-Computer, also einen richtigen 32-Bit-CPU zu bauen, mit so einer fetten Backplane, also eine lange Platine mit vielen Slots und dann steckten eben die einzelnen Elemente dieser CPU da drin und das Ding war halt vergleichsweise komplex, fett. Sehr schön allerdings, dass man da vor Ort sich auch die ausgedruckten Schaltpläne anschauen konnte und auch die, mich damals noch so ein bisschen mit Fragezeichen zurücklassenden Listings des Microcodes. Das heißt, der Microcode, also quasi im ROM der CPU befindlichen Schaltzustände, die die ganze CPU einnehmen muss, um bestimmte Instruktionen abarbeiten zu können. Das waren also meterlange Listen auf breitem Druckerpapier und ich hatte da keine Zeit und diesmal habe ich mir die Zeit genommen, um mir das mal von demjenigen, der das auch wirklich zusammengelötet hat, haarklein erläutern lassen, wie das so funktioniert. Das werde ich jetzt hier nicht so wiederholen, aber ich war auf Betriebstemperatur. Das hat mich schon mal ganz wuschig gemacht, weil ich habe es dann auch verstanden und dieses ganze Konzept begriffen, wie eigentlich so Microcode abgelegt wird und was der eigentlich genau steuert und was es bedeutet, diese ganzen States, diese ganzen Zustände in einer CPU zu haben, die eben sagen, was als nächstes geschehen soll. Soweit so uninteressant für die meisten, die das hören. Dann war ich damit fertig, bin so ein bisschen weitermarschiert und hab geguckt, was denn noch so zu holen ist und dann gab es noch richtiges CPU-Gold direkt ein paar Meter weiter und da bin ich einfach mal komplett in die Knie gegangen und das möchte ich euch mal versuchen, ein bisschen näher zu bringen. Auch hier handelt es sich um so ein Freak-Projekt. Zwei Holländer, die sich hingesetzt haben und auch gesagt haben, wäre in seinem Leben keine CPU gebaut hat, der braucht gar nicht erst mal eine Bäume pflanzen anfangen und Kinderzeugen wollen wir gar nicht reden und haben das Projekt gestartet namens Gigatron. Gigatron TTL Mikrocomputer. Und dieser Gigatron, also wer jetzt bei diesem Thema schon nicht komplett abgesprungen ist und so ein bisschen da eine A dafür hat, das müssen wir euch mal angucken. Das ist einfach wirklich, wirklich charming. Was ist das Ding? Also zunächst einmal handelt es sich hier um so eine Platine ungefähr so den A4 quer. Wird hier schön präsentiert unter so einem kleinen Glaskasten und ist eine CPU, die sehr klein ist. Ist eine 8-Bit-CPU und dieses Teil ist auf eine beeindruckende Art und Weise extrem runtergedampft. Also es ist wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr einfach und verzichtet auch auf diesen komplexen Microcode, der so eine CPU ein bisschen schwerer nachzuvollziehen macht in seiner ganzen Schaltung. Also wenn man sich die Schaltung eine Weile anschaut, da muss man auch gar nicht so viel wissen über Computer an sich. Wenn man so ein bisschen das mit dem Binärsystem und wie man so Zahlen zusammenrechnet verstanden hat, dann kommt man da relativ schnell auf das Aha. Und ich saß so ein bisschen davor und hatte so ein Aha nach dem anderen und war erstmal total erstaunt, wie wenig Bausteine da überhaupt drauf waren und erklärte mir halt, wie er dieses Ding gemacht hat. Und das irre ist, das Teil ist also ein Acht-Bit-Rechner in der sogenannten Harvard-Architektur. Also im Gegensatz zu der von Neumann-Architektur ist bei der Harvard-Architektur Daten und Programmen getrennt. Das heißt, diese CPU hat eigentlich nur so einen kleinen ROM-Bereich, wo so der Kerncode drin ist und mehr gibt es nicht. Und der Datenbereich, was war das eigentlich, hab ich mir das aufgeschrieben, das war gar nicht so viel, das waren so einige 32 Kilobyte oder sowas. Da liegt an sich kein Programm drin. Das heißt, die CPU kann in seinem RAM nicht direkt Code exekutieren, sondern kann eigentlich nur Code im ROM exekutieren. Und ich wunderte mich die ganze Zeit über dieses Design und wie denn das überhaupt flexible Software sein kann. Und bevor ich auf diese Software nochmal komme, noch eine Besonderheit. An dieses Ding war ein VGA-Kabel angeschlossen und das Teil zeigte auf dem Bildschirm, hab ich die Auflösung aufgeschrieben, irgendwie sowas wie 160 Pixel mal 320, irgendwie sowas in der Größenordnung, muss ich da nochmal klicken, in Farbe an. Und das Irre ist, ich blickte auf eine extrem einfache Schaltung mit wirklich einer Handvoll ICs, ich weiß nicht, wie viel es sind, irgendwie 20 oder so.
Gute Schätzung, ja.
Und das ist die komplette CPU. Und man blickt nur auf eine CPU und dann steckt da hinten ein VGA-Stecker dran, wo ein Farbbild bei rauskommt. Ich dachte, wie geht das überhaupt? Wie funktioniert das überhaupt? Das Ding läuft, glaube ich, mit 8 Megahertz oder so. Und die Wahrheit ist jetzt, dass diese Farbausgabe auf dem Bildschirm tatsächlich mit einem 8-Bit-Register gemacht wird, von dem die ersten zwei Bit rot, die nächsten zwei Bit grün, blau und dann die anderen beiden Bits für die vertikale und die horizontale Syncing gemacht wird. Und dass ungefähr 80 Prozent der CPU-Leistung hier permanent nur damit beschäftigt ist, auf diesem Bildschirm synchron ein Bild anzuzeigen. Das heißt, die ganze CPU, die da gebaut ist, ist die ganze Zeit eigentlich, nicht heiß glühend, aber die ganze Zeit im Betrieb und nur die anderen 20 Prozent, wenn nichts auf dem Bildschirm gemacht werden muss, also sprich in den Abtastlücken zwischen den Zeilen und beim Bildwechsel, nur das bleibt sozusagen über, um auf diesem Teil eigentlich noch was Sinnvolles zu machen. Ein irres Konzept, was ich so überhaupt noch nie gesehen habe, aber das, was total gaga ist, ist, das Ding war in der Lage, über einen VGA- Stecker auf einem Monitor ein Farbpixel-Bildschirm zu machen und da liefen dann auch Spiele drauf. Auf einer super runtergedampften CPU. Da habe ich mich gefragt, na okay, aber wenn das Ding nur ROM hat, hat er dann die ganzen Spiele im ROM? Nein, in diesem ROM befindet sich im Prinzip nichts anderes als ein Bytecode-Interpreter, sodass er quasi die eigentliche Software, die dann ein 16-Bit-Bytecode ist, also mit richtig interessanten Instruktionen, die aber alle quasi nur so als Bytecode-Interpreter implementiert sind, das steckt da in diesem ROM. Und das kann dann halt einfach ins RAM geladen werden und dann kann man diesem Teil beliebige Programme beibringen. Also ich fand das so mind-boggling, wie die alles beiseite gelegt haben, wie man so CPUs normalerweise baut und wie man CPUs nachbaut und mit so wenig Bausteinen eine vollständig funktionierende 8-Bit-CPU, die man aber in 16-Bit programmieren kann, die auch noch in der Lage ist, einen Farbbildschirm anzusprechen und darauf Spiele spielen zu können. Und das alles in so einem kleinen, gepackten Teil für wenig Geld. Hammer, super Dokumentation, sehr hübsches Handbuch. Toll, ich bin begeistert.
Excluding Shipping. Das ist das Kit.
Der Gigatron TTL-Color-Computer, also wirklich ein super Bastelding. Und es gibt auch schöne Talks von einem von den beiden Entwicklern auf YouTube, wo einiges schon ganz gut erklärt wird. Ich hab mich mit dem anderen unterhalten, sehr nette Leute, also toll.
Es gibt auch einen Online-Emulator.
Ja, richtig, genau. Und irgendjemand hat dann in JavaScript das Ding dann irgendwie komplett emuliert. Das hat irgendwie ein anderes für sie gemacht, wo man diese ganze Software auch schon mal laufen lassen kann.
Ja, ich hatte, als ich das Thema da gesehen hatte, Vintage-Computing und so, bin ich nämlich kürzlich auch auf so ein Stück Vintage gestoßen, weswegen ich auch vorhin sagte, seit 20 oder 40 Jahren dreht sich eigentlich in der IT alles nur im Kreis. Alles ist schon erfunden, alle Probleme sind schon längst gelöst und es geht eigentlich nur darum, mit mehr CPU-Bezyklen mehr rauszuholen aus den bekannten Konzepten. Da habe ich letztens mal wieder den Film Tron gesehen, den alten, und wollte dann nochmal in der Wikipedia nachschauen, wie eigentlich so nochmal diese Effekte gemacht wurden, weil die ja Frame für Frame übergepinselt haben und dann auch teilweise dreifach die Computer-Animationen, Schauspieler und Special Effects übereinander belichtet haben. Weswegen dann auch diese Flicker, also alles warbert ja dann auch so ein bisschen und so weiter. Dann habe ich das so gelesen und gelesen und so. Und dann kam irgendwie so ein Aspekt, dass das Bit, was ja auch in dem Film vorkommt, Ja! Oder Yes! Dass das ja mit einem Speech-Synthesizer bespielt wurde. Also das kam halt aus einer Maschine. Und da dachte ich mir, speech-synthesizer war natürlich auch verlinkt, so typischer Wikipedia-Effekt, gleich mal draufklicken. Und dann kam hervor der Votrax Speech-Synthesizer. Und ich hab hier in den Show Notes mal ein Video verlinkt. Das sollte man jetzt nicht in der Gänze gucken. Das packen wir aber gleich noch in die Show Notes vielleicht. Und da hat ein alter Entwickler, der eine Version dieses Gerätes gebaut oder entwickelt hat, das Ding im Keller hinter Spinnenweben und so weiter gefunden. Und hat das wieder ausgepackt, hat es an Monitor angeschlossen, hat sein Manual gelesen und den Code wieder ins Terminal getippt und lässt den dann halt wieder so Sachen sagen. Und ich glaube, dieses Modell ist von 1979. Und wenn man dann das Video anguckt, das ist auch ein relativ simples Design. Allerdings der IC ist quasi der Speech Synthes, also die haben einen eigenen Chip gebaut dafür. Und hast du ja gerade Ton da?
Ich kann Ton anmachen, soll ich?
Ja, wenn du gleich den mal sprechen lässt. Tut er das hier schon? Gleich geht's los, ja.
Okay, dann mal. Okay, noch ein bisschen Forstgippen.
Er zeigt auf jeden Fall auch schön den Maschinencode. Ach so, ist Basic.
Auf dem Pad ist das oder was? Oder auf 8032?
Kann ich dir nicht sagen. Jetzt stellt er ihn an und erst mal so... Es ist halt Synthesizer quasi. Also er brummt jetzt erstmal monoton. Kann er auf den Pitch-Man stellen. Wenn man mal hört, was damals schon so für... Wer sagt jetzt immer das Gleiche, ne? Pitch und so weiter, jetzt kannst du es auch schon abbrechen, weil ich glaube, in dem Video sagt er jetzt nicht mehr viel mehr, aber es gibt da noch so YouTube-Videos, wo sich zwei so ne Votrackmaschinen, so einen Monty-Python-Joke gegenseitig erzählen und so weiter, ne? Aber jetzt kommt der nächste Kracher. Das ist alles auch schon alte Scheiße. Ich glaube im Workflow hatte ich das auch verlinkt. The Voder 1939, the first electronic voice synthesizer. Und da gibt es dann so ein Video, ich weiß jetzt nicht so Weltausstellungen, aber sowas in der Art. Und im Prinzip haben sie das gleiche Prinzip angewendet, dass sie eine Maschine gebaut haben, wo man Silben modulieren kann. Aber das ist noch voll manuell. Die Frau, die das bedient, die hat sozusagen so eine Klaviatur und Pedale für Pitch und Vibrator und so weiter. Und es werden auch im Prinzip schon da die Erkenntnisse für menschliche Sprache. Also die sind da schon mehr oder weniger...
Runehmer und so.
Genau, und wenn es halt monoton einfach nur der gleiche Pitch bleibt, dass es halt sehr künstlich und unverständlich klingt und dass so ein gewisses Vibrator und so weiter haben muss. Ja, skipp mal einfach mal ein bisschen rein. Ja, mach mal.
Und das, wie du bemerkst, ist wirklich ein Singen-Ton. Ja, Voder kann nicht nur reden, aber auch singen. Okay, und irgendwann sagt er... Und wie ist es mit O-Lang-Zai? O-Lang-Zai?
Und dieses in den 80ern, das sind dann alles schon Special Chips, die sozusagen diese Phoneme oder Silben und so alles schon vorgekodet haben. Man kann einfach Programme schreiben, die dann diese Silben aneinanderketten und so. Und da dachte ich mir auch so irgendwie wow, mindblown und irgendwie jetzt denkt man sich ja so exponentielle Entwicklungen und so weiter. Und ich mein, so viel besser ist dieses Siri jetzt dann am Ende. Also nun, aber ja, fand ich auf jeden Fall auch mal interessant. Da gibt es in der Wikipedia auch wirklich genau hier pustet auch schon immer den Link zur Sprachsynthese und so. Das ist so ein Thema, da hatte ich auch vorher noch nie reingeguckt und war echt erstmal beeindruckt mit wie, also mit welchen simplen Mitteln da schon relativ früh die Leute zu Gange waren.
Im Chat erwähnen das auch schon einige Leute, hat mich auch gleich natürlich an Hal erinnern und irgendwie so Daisy, Daisy, give me your answer, du.
Ja und das interessante ist halt auch, dass die, also das liest man dann auch in den Artikeln zu der Sprachsynthese, dass auch Sprachwissenschaftler darüber auch mehr über die menschliche Sprache überhaupt oder Sprachen als sich verstanden haben, weil die natürlich die ganze Zeit daran geforscht haben. So ähnlich wie beim Fliegen. Also wie kriegen wir jetzt das mit dem Fliegen hin und dann imitieren wir jetzt irgendwie dann Vögel oder versuchen es irgendwie und das ist alles so ein bisschen krude, bis dann irgendjemand den richtigen Dreh gefunden hat. Und im Prinzip ist das mit dieser Sprachsynthese auch ähnlich. Und irgendwann haben dann auch die Sprachwissenschaftler durch diese ganzen Versuche, das zu imitieren, irgendwie verstanden. Ach so, ja, stimmt, das kann man vielleicht so strukturieren und kategorisieren. Ja, sehr interessant. Und es gibt auch Emulatoren von diesen alten Sprachsynthesizen. Und ich bilde mir ein, auch schon so Android-Bausätze oder so gesehen zu haben, wo man das dann auch wieder sich alles nochmal nachbauen kann, was natürlich einen begrenzten Mehrwert bietet.
Außer Spaß.
Welcome to the Freak Show, the best podcast on the planet.
Das ist hier Rainer gerade reingeschmissen. Google Cloud, AI, tralala Text to Speech.
Was kannst du bei Voice Type einstellen?
80 Jahre später.
Voice Type, Basic oder WaveNet?
Na, wenigstens nicht Skynet.
Wir können ja auch, geht auch Deutsch? Nee, Deutsch geht nicht, oder? Doch, Deutsch geht auch.
Im Walde sitzt ein Auerhahn, der schaut mich ganz schön sauer an.
Naja, da geht noch was.
Ja, das Ding ist halt auch, Englisch ist halt immer ganz ganz vorne mit dabei, wobei ich eigentlich erwarten würde, dass jetzt sowas wie Chinesisch oder so vielleicht das auch mal überholen könnte, aber ja, Englisch ist prinzipiell immer so die beste Demo.
Ja, ich freu mich nur gerade, warum das eine männliche Stimme und hier eine weibliche Stimme ist. Gibt's hier noch einen anderen Voice-Name?
Im Walde sitzt ein Auerhahn, der schaut mich ganz schön sauer an.
Am Auerhahn, da sind sie aber ganz schön am Zusammenbrechen.
Das war schon besser. Hier würd ich was abkaufen.
Im Walde sitzt ein Auerhahn, der schaut mich ganz schön sauer an.
Von dir kauf ich nix. Also ich will unbedingt ein dateship.de.de WaveNet C haben. Das ist hier die Basis von Google Duplex, heißt es hier gerade. Das hängt natürlich da alles zusammen.
Das ist das mit dem, machst für dich Friseur Termin.
Oder es ruft dich an für einen Friseur Termin.
Jetzt weißt du auf welche Stimmen du achten musst.
Ich warte auf den Tag, wo diese ganzen Systeme sich gegenseitig anrufen und versuchen herauszufinden, ob sie irgendwie Maschinen sind oder nicht.
Ist das eigentlich, was für ein Frequenzband hat, so neuere Telefonie? Kann man das noch als Mensch hören?
Die Telefonie?
Naja, jetzt kommt mal an, auf dein Deck-Telefon wird angerufen. Wann, wie weit ist der Frequenzband? Weil die könnten ja irgendwie Frequenzen nehmen, was für die Menschen halt gar nicht mehr hörbar ist.
Ach so, das meinst du sozusagen. Nicht hörbare Frequenzen. Also bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, aber die neuen High-Quality-Profite, die jetzt auch auf GSM freigeschaltet werden, die haben schon so einen typischen Hi-Fi-Range. Ich würde mal vermuten, dass die dann halt auch 44 Kilohertz machen und das oder halt auch mit 16.
Aber das wäre ja noch im Rahmen sozusagen.
Ja, dann kannst du dann mit 20 Kilohertz irgendwie hörst dann halt schon nicht mehr, aber die Maschinen schon. Du meinst, die Computer rufen sich heimlich gegenseitig an, aber du hörst es nicht.
Die flüstern sich auf 60 Kilohertz, irgendwelche. Anrufen ist auch so ein Konzept für Menschen. Also da fliegen die ganze Zeit Pakete, die müssen sich dann einen grünen Knopf drücken, um sich zu unterhalten.
Das ist ja das Lustige, dass sozusagen Google rüstet hier die Smartphones auf, damit sie irgendwie Restaurant buchen. Die buchen sich bei Google aber wiederum den Voicebox-Service, der dann den Leuten automatisch die Bestellung abnimmt, damit sie das nicht selber machen müssen. Und am Ende unterhalten sich halt die Google-Bots miteinander und wissen es nicht. Und dann gibt es dann so Thresholds mit irgendwie Creepiness.
Oder die haben so Keywords, so irgendwelches. Und dann Skynet.
Da gab es aber beim letzten Kongressen einen sehr schönen Talk dazu, wie man Menschen automatisiert. Das ist ja eigentlich das quasi. Es gibt ja glaube ich von Amazon auch so die Mechanical Turks, wo du jetzt beispielsweise so ein Set an Bildern hoch lädst und willst du irgendwie was von einem Menschen erkannt haben. Damit automatisierst du ja eigentlich Menschen am Ende. Das ist ja genau das Gleiche.
Aber wenn du dann wieder eine AI dahinsetzt und easy deine Mechanical Turk-Kohle abkassierst und die dann auf Amazon laufen lässt, als Amazon Lambda, genau. Oh Gott, the end is near.
Haben wir noch genügend Zeit für das Frontend-Thema? Das ist aber ein weites Thema. Das kann ich aber nicht alleine bargern.
Wir sind ja auch zu dritt.
Können wir noch mal kurz zwei weltliche Dinge noch kurz...
Also es ist schon 23 Uhr, ne Tim?
Ja, deswegen dachte ich, kann ich die vielleicht mal kurz...
Nee, lass uns das doch mal anders machen. Lass uns doch mal die weltlichen Dinge ganz zum Schluss, wenn die Aufmerksamkeit schon am Ende...
Es passt aber jetzt einfach gerade viel zu gut.
Aber die Frontend...
Ganz kurz, ich möchte euch ja nur einen Talk empfehlen, dann kommen wir zum Frontend.
Noch mal die ganzen anderen Themen vorher.
Ich möchte euch einen Talk empfehlen. Dieser Talk ist ganz unterhaltsam. Heißt Machine Learning Failures for Art. Und ist ein Talk von Janelle Shane, die macht irgendwie Kunst mit AI. Und das ist wirklich sehr unterhaltsam, weil sie in dem Talk so verschiedene Fehler von AI-Erkennungssystemen entlarvt. Also, dass AIs offensichtlich, gerade so Fotoerkennungsdinger, kommen mir mal super schlau vor. Weil du wirfst irgendwie so Bilder dazu. Und dann sagst du halt, dann siehst du so ein Bild, Landschaft mit Schafen. Und dann die Beschreibung so total akkurat, eine schöne Landschaft mit Grazing Sheep. Und dann ist ich mit Photoshop beigegangen und hatte dann einfach mal bestimmte Features aus diesem Foto rausgenommen. Unter anderem die Schafe mit dem Ergebnis, dass die Beschreibung immer noch dieselbe war. Und hat dann langsam aufgedeckt, wie quasi diese ganzen Trainingsmethoden in die falsche Richtung führen. Weil eigentlich ganz andere Dinge hier erkannt und dann als das Richtige bezeichnet werden, als das, was man jetzt glaubt, was das Ding tatsächlich sieht. Und führt dann eben auch sehr schön raus, wie auch Dinge, die nicht da sind, irgendwie interessant waren. Also zum Beispiel konnte man dann irgendwie dieses Thema auch immer wieder fragen, wie viele Grafen in diesem Bild sind. Ja, Null und so. Sehr lustig zu sehen. Ich muss gerade mal überlegen, ob ich aus meinen Notizen noch ein paar andere, lustige Bilder vergleiche mit Bildern von My Little Pony versus Pony versus Metal, um sozusagen den Pony-Einteil eines Bildes oder eines Charakters zu machen. Also wie fluffig, flauschig, ponnihaft ist das jetzt oder wie sehr ist das jetzt Heavy Metal irgendwie? Und dann hat sie unter anderem Star Wars Charakter vorgelegt. Und Darth Vader war 82 Prozent Pony. Und noch mehr so Dinge. Also ich will jetzt gar nicht so viel verraten. Schaut euch einfach den Talk an, wenn ihr Lust habt. Mein Tipp ist sehr unterhaltsam.
Da hätte ich noch ein lustiges Bild, was dazu passt.
Das habe ich irgendwie, ich glaube, gestern auf Twitter gefunden. Und das war irgendwie ganz großartig von so Menschen, die irgendwie meinten, sich eine Mindmap zu machen, was wichtig ist zu lernen. Und da findet man dann halt so wie total useful und so weiter und nicht wirklich zeitintensiv das zu lernen. Data vs. Und was total not useful und total time consuming ist, Math and Statistics. Und halt natürlich AI und Machine Learning kommt da auch davor. Also so eine Leute sind wirklich geil.
Mathematik ist nicht so nützlich, meinste?
Brauchst du Ferien auch gar nicht.
Nee, also braucht man bei Visualisierung auch nicht und Statistik auch nicht. Das kann man einfach direkt vergessen. Ja, da wusste ich, dass das mit der Mindmap wirklich nochmal was wird. Fertig mit den weltlichen Themen?
Du weißt nicht, Huckel wollte noch über seine Apple Watch reden.
Nee, nee, lass mal hier die Frontend-Thematik aus dem Sack. Die Apple Watch, die kann warten.
Wie geht's eigentlich dem Frontend?
Ja, da war zu dritt mal quasi die Mehrheit bilden. Weißte nicht, wir wollten mal oder ich würde gerne mal irgendwie so einen quasi kurzen Abriss, was so in den letzten Jahren im Frontend passiert ist. Weil ich glaube, die Tendenz bei der Freak Show normalerweise nicht ganz so in die Richtung geht.
Das ist völlig in Ordnung.
Der Frontend Report ist schamlos.
Wir brauchen mehr Singles hier für unsere Segmente.
Da musst du mal methodisch inkorrekt mal anfragen. Die haben noch ein paar übrig.
Ich glaube, Rainer hat dann auch bestimmt noch schnell wieder was.
Ja, wir haben Rainer.
Das ist ein ganz, das kann man auch ganz einfach fassen, das Thema. Also, es hat sich viel verändert. Das ist erstmal der Einstieg. Und so Disclaimer, auch wir Frontend-Entwickler wären froh, wenn es weniger, wie soll ich sagen, weit gefächert wäre, glaube ich.
Weniger Tooling?
Weniger Tooling, weniger, weil der so gängige oder der gängige Ruf von Frontend-Entwicklung ist ja, dass es für relativ einfache Sachen schon verdammt kompliziert ist, das was man da überhaupt auf die Beine stellen muss. Und der Hauptgrund dafür ist eigentlich, dass wir ja keine richtige, verlässliche Laufzeit haben, in der wir operieren. Also, wenn Huckel jetzt so seine Experimente mit Vanilla Script macht im latest Safari oder latest Chrome, das ist cool, das macht auch Spaß. Und dann macht man halt die App irgendwie in einem Firefox vor drei Jahren auf und dann macht's einfach rums und das war's. Aber wenn man quasi für Anwendungen, die eine breite Nutzerschaft treffen soll, was entwickelt, muss man halt das Ganze beachten. Und da ist halt in den letzten Jahren sehr viel Tooling dazugekommen. Das fängt halt so an. Ich glaube, ich schreib zumindest mindestens ECMAScript 6.
Ja, ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, ob es jetzt 6, 7, 8, was das ist.
Ja, der 7 ist ja noch nicht standardisiert, aber es gibt ja schon mal so Propos, die man verwendet.
Manche Funktionen verwendet man ja schon. Ich schreib auch ausschließlich nur noch ES6. Dafür muss ich halt kompilieren.
Ich in der Tat nur, wenn ich richtig dran denke. Ich merke, dass ich dann an einigen Stellen nicht dran denke und noch so in diesen Muscle Memory drin bin, weil ich halt ein gutes halbes Jahr im Backend verbracht habe. Und jetzt wieder zurückkommen. Das ist dann so dieses, ah fuck, das ist schon wieder kein ES6.
Was ist denn ES6? Ne, das weiß ich schon, aber was ist denn jetzt da?
Nehmen wir mal den Klassiker, du hast einen Array und machst eine For Each darüber. Da hast du ja wieder deine Funktion da drin und irgendwie Klammern gedreht. Genau, und jetzt nimmst du halt die Arrow Functions.
Die werden übrigens auch net Farts genannt.
Okay, dann weiß ich schon.
Oder Comst und Legend.
Alles klar, weiß ich Bescheid.
Alles so Kleinigkeiten und dann hast du dich an deine Arrow Functions gewöhnt. Dann bist du wieder bei View und musst aber an einigen Stellen Funktion hinschreiben. Das ist dann wieder so, wo du dir irgendwann denkst, ach fuck, jetzt musst du wieder so rumdenken.
Naja, weil es halt nicht semantisch dasselbe ist.
Genau, und vorher hast du da nie den Unterschied drin gesehen. Oder nur, wenn du drüber nachgedacht hast.
Ja, eigentlich, du könntest, also das einzuführen ist zwar sehr nett für so Sachen, wo du keinen Kontext oder sowas mit pflegen musst oder wo du keinen neuen Kontext einführen möchtest, aber es sieht halt auch sehr schick aus.
Weniger Text.
Genau, und damit wir überall ES6 schreiben können, haben wir quasi Pre-Compiler. Das heißt, das kompelliert uns dann den ganzen Scheiß in ECMAScript 5, was wir dann überall ausführen können. Und abhängig von deinem Browser und was du haben möchtest, hast du dann das Tooling am Start, was meistens sitzt mit Babel. Babel ist ein sehr cooles Projekt, da das quasi ist so ein Runtime, ja so ein Runtime-Compiler, der abhängig davon, was du für Browser adressierst, dir genau die Funktionalität auf ECMAScript 5 umsetzt, die du dann auch benötigst. Und da kannst du auch sowas sagen, so wie ich hätte gerne irgendwie die 2% oder bzw. 98% der Browser, weil mir die 2% eigentlich ziemlich egal sind.
Die 2%, die dann wirklich noch den Internet Explorer benutzen, die werden schon nicht ankommen.
Ja, genau.
Außer das sind die Kunden.
Ja genau, bitte nutze keinen Internet.
Ja, eigentlich braucht man genau für JavaScript brauchst du einen Pre-Compiler, wenn du große Style Sheets hast.
Da gibt es auch nochmal was extra.
Schreibst du viel CSS, was heißt das jetzt? Vier variablen Vanilla CSS wieder oder?
Also das kommt drauf an. Auf Arbeit schreib ich keinen CSS. Nein, weil wir haben die Designsysteme dafür. Weil du willst halt nicht, dass jeder Entwickler anfängt, so seinen eigenen Homebrew CSS Garten aufzuspannen, sondern du hast halt dann schon ein Set an Klassen und ein Set an Komponenten, was du verwendest. Aber so jetzt für ein Player oder sowas? Ja, das ist dann...
Ich hab jetzt auch was Neues gelernt. So eine Komponenten-Library, wo du sozusagen deinen ganzen Style-Guide in Code machen kannst und deine Komponenten... Also du hast halt verschiedene Ebenen, du fängst so bei Atommolekülen und so weiter. Da gibt es da so verschiedene Unterteilungen. Du kannst halt wirklich die Kleinstbausteile definieren und daraus baust du dann die Molo-Eküle und dann gibt es noch Organismen und dann kannst du aber einen selbst dokumentierten Style-Guide haben, der alle Elemente dokumentiert, dir das HTML die Klassen rausgibt und dann hast du zumindest so einen... Ja, naja, ich kann euch das mal zeigen, wie das hier so aussieht zum Beispiel. Vielleicht finde ich das ja gerade noch, aber ja mach...
Also wir machen das halt auf einer Komponenten-Ebene. Bei uns Komponente bedeutet quasi HTML-Elemente, die zu einer UI-Komponente zusammen sich zusammenpassen.
Aber ihr werdet ja auch Subkomponenten haben, oder? Eine Komponente könnte ja dann einen Button beinhalten und das wäre dann wieder...
Abhängig von den Kontexten sieht der Button halt dann eventuell anders aus.
Ja, bei großen Projekten nutzt man so Living Style Guides eigentlich schon oft.
Genau, weil das fand ich halt als Entwickler ganz cool, weil man dann... Ich zeige jetzt den Leuten mal, wie so ein Frachtel dann aussieht. Dann hat man hier links so seine Molecule, zum Beispiel wie ein Alert aussieht. Und dann gibt es hier unten gleich quasi das HTML und die Assets, die dazu nötig sind, und das CSS. Und man kann als Entwickler, der das dann vielleicht umsetzen muss, gleich copy und pasten da draus und hat sozusagen so eine selbstdokumentierende Style Guide. Oder Living Style Guide, ja. Also genau, das wäre dann sozusagen die Frage, ich kannte jetzt nur Fractal.
Na, wie nennen das, oder das bezeichne ich als Designsystem oder so. Weil du hast ja noch so ein, es gibt immer so Randfälle, die du nicht unbedingt abbilden kannst, dann hast du halt aber auch bestimmte Design-Tokens, die du weiterverwendest. Dass du halt jetzt nicht wieder anfängst, irgendwie deine eigene Farbe zu definieren, sondern die kriegst du halt über einen Token dann da mit dran.
Was ich bei Fractal tatsächlich relativ doof fand, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt an der fehlenden Erfahrung lag, dass man halt nicht so supergut vererben konnte und dann viel in diesem Style Guide duplizieren musste.
Das ist generell so ein, das ist so ein Grenzgang, weil du, also so für, also generell meiner Meinung nach ist HTML und CSS nicht so richtig geil dafür geeignet, um Applikationen zu bauen. Das ist ja so der Fluch, den man jetzt gerade so hat. Wir versuchen irgendwie das, was wir so auf einem iOS oder so in einer Cocoa-App sieht, versuchen wir zu imitieren mit HTML und CSS.
Endlich sagt es mal jemand.
Die Anforderung schwappt halt zurück. Und auf einmal muss deine Webseite genauso responsiv und genauso flutschen wie deine App. Und da ist aber ein sehr alter Standard, auf den man am Ende aufsetzt. Und das so weit hinzubringen, dass das überhaupt funktioniert, bedarf halt sehr viel Tooling.
Wobei, diese Pre-Compiler, die kann ich ja auf jeden Fall nachvollziehen, das ist ja total sinnvoll im Vergleich zu früher, mit ich mach mir meine Browser-Weiche selber und so. Aber warum gibt es denn 23 Paket-Manager?
Naja, eigentlich gibt es nur zwei gerade.
Aber was schreibt denn, das würde mich mal interessieren, was schreibst du denn gerade überwiegend, Michaela? Nee, ich meine CSS-mäßig.
In React Native ist es CSS. Wenn ich selber entwickle, schreibe ich, wenn ich nicht React schreibe, wo das CSS im JS ist und sowieso gescoped und so weiter, dann mache ich SCSS. Und ich bin da auch noch nicht von weg, weil es gibt CSS-Variablen, das ist alles schön und gut, aber ich benutze einfach andere Funktionen von SCSS.
Ja, gerade die Mixins und sowas, die du verwenden willst, das ist schon sehr praktisch.
Ja, aber ich konnte jetzt auch, wenn jemand will, dass ich Less schreibe, dann schreibe ich das auch. Aber Less ist nicht mehr so richtig, glaube ich, das machen nicht mehr viele.
Das hat sich auch wieder überlebt. Das ist auch so ein Ding, die Iterationszyklen von bestimmten Technologien in der Frontend wird es sehr cool.
Ich mochte SCSS immer ein bisschen lieber als das, weil wenigstens so die Syntax eben noch CSS ist und nicht ganz anders aussieht.
Genau, aber neben Babel hat man auch solche Sachen wie TypeScript oder PureScript, was ganz interessant ist, was auch so als, ich weiß nicht, ob ich Precompiler benennen würde, weil TypeScript ja auch schon ein richtiges Typesystem, der da noch mit drauf flascht.
Ja, und Static Analysis halt, ne? Weil das hatte ich hier auch, glaube ich, mal in der Freak Show schon erwähnt, dass jetzt wo ich dann mal wieder ein bisschen mehr JavaScript gemacht hatte, so dachte, es gibt Funktionen, die haben zwei Argumente, aber man kann sie mit 0, 1, 2 oder unendlich vielen Argumenten aufrufen, es gibt nie einen Fehler. Und dafür sind dann halt natürlich so, also ich hab tatsächlich TypeScript und so weiter noch nicht ausprobiert, ich hab nur davon gelesen, weil für mein kleines Chat-Dings bin ich auch so jetzt klargekommen, sag ich mal, aber das erschien mir tatsächlich so einigermaßen sinnvoll. Weil diese reinen Static Analysis Tools, ich hab bestimmt wieder den Namen vergessen, die es ja auch jetzt für JavaScript gibt, die kommen halt so ganz alleine ohne sozusagen Annotationshilfe des Entwicklers auch nicht klar und dann kann man auch gleich diesen Pre-Compiler, oder wie soll man sagen, naja, Makrosprache ist es nicht wirklich, aber man weiß schon, man hat dann an Sonntags, die sozusagen diese Typ-Annotation gleich mitbaut.
Wobei TypeScript, das hat Vor- und Nachteile tatsächlich. Die, also TypeScript ist ja ein Superset von JavaScript, also du kannst normal einen JavaScript-Code da rein pasten, das funktioniert, aber wenn du deine Typen nicht definierst, also für die Standard-Browser-APIs kriegst du das von, die Typings von TypeScript gratis mit, das ist eigentlich ziemlich praktisch. Aber wenn du jetzt eigene Funktionen ohne Interfaces oder sowas und richtigen Typen-Definitionen definierst, dann hast du auch keinen großen Vorteil daraus. Das heißt, das erfordert noch mal eine Entwicklerdisziplin, das zu tun. Und gerade wenn du irgendwie in so einem Frontend-Bereich bist, dann...
also ich hab das in einem Projekt eingesetzt, als ich am Anfang das Frontend gemacht habe. Und ich fand das am Anfang auch so großartig, so kannst du alles irgendwie schön definieren. Und dann bist du aber manchmal so an den Punkt gekommen, wo du dachtest, man, ich will das jetzt einfach nur mal schnell ausprobieren. Und schon hast du wieder kein richtiges Interface eingenommen, sondern eher so diesen generischen Typ, ja hier eine Matte und passt schon. Und dann fängst du halt an wieder so dreckig dann zu kronen. Und das finde ich ist halt auch echt doof. Ich hab mich immer selber darüber so geärgert, weil eigentlich wollte ich das halt ordentlich und schön durchziehen. Und dann ist das halt in so einem Dirty dahingerotzen wieder geändert.
Ja, das lässt aber Typescope zu tatsächlich.
Genau, aber es lässt es zu. Und an der Stelle dachte ich mir immer so, ja.
Ja, das ist halt schwierig. Du hast halt manchmal behinderts dich halt auch bei der, was heißt behindert? Im Endeffekt, wenn du irgendwie Probleme mit deinen Interfaces hast, dann musst du halt nochmal drüber nachdenken, ob du das jetzt gerade richtig implementierst oder gerade nur versuchst daran vorbeizuarbeiten.
Genau, und wenn du dann aber so was, wenn du der Single-Point-Of-Failure bist und halt gerade versuchst so das Interface zum einzumachen und dann aber halt vorne das Styling halt auch und du denkst so, jetzt gib mir einfach nur mal kurz, was ich so habe, ich hab das grad nicht so im Kopf. Ja, dann ohne Interface läuft da halt nix.
Ja, na es gibt nochmal extremere Spielformen davon. Das ist hier so Reason-mäßig, das ist eine Okamelsprache. Dann kannst du da wirklich keinen JavaScript mehr reinpacken oder kein ECMAScript, die ECMAScript zum Tag, sondern da musst du wirklich halt dann Okamel schreiben. Was aber dann natürlich konsequent ist.
Und hast du da mal Elm ausprobiert?
Elm hab ich auch mal ausprobiert, wobei Elm halt nochmal Du wolltest doch, dass wir das neue Tool... Ja, ich wollte das neue Tool in Elm schreiben, weil das Elm eigentlich nicht nur so eine, das gibt dir, das löst viele Probleme, weil es hat einen eigenen Paketenmanager, natürlich.
Ich denk mir eigentlich auch daran, diese ganze Plittoria von Abkürzungen mal zu verlinken.
Ich dachte, das ist selbst eignen, ja, können wir machen.
Reiner macht das die ganze Zeit.
Reiner kann doch nicht alles machen. Also wir brauchen glaube ich mal einen professionellen Show-Noter, das meine ich auch ernst.
Gab es da nicht mal ein Projekt dazu?
Ne, nur mal für die Freak Show. Wenn sich da jemand finden sollte, bitte melde dich. Ich wäre da sehr empfänglich für. Einfach so jemand, der so Live-Show-Notes macht, das wäre top.
Akronyme in URLs verwandelt.
Okay, ich pack mal im...
Ja, weil am Ende muss ich das immer alles zusammenfegen. Und das ist immer so, wenn ich mit dem Schnitt durch bin und alles und so und dann so, ja, eigentlich könnte ich selbst veröffentlichen, aber die Show-Notes. Und dann leg ich mich dann doch erstmal wieder schlafen und gras ich diesen Slack ab und alles so.
Ja, Elm ist nicht nur, also Elm hat ein eigenes Paketsystem. Das hat aber auch eine eigene Syntax. Und es hat vor allen Dingen eine eigene Architektur. Das heißt, mit Elm kannst du nicht einfach deine Architektur umsetzen, die du dir jetzt gerade im Kopf hast, sondern das hat ein ganz spezielles Pattern, wie du eine Applikation bauen möchtest. Was cool ist, wenn du, weil damit, du musst dich daran halten, weil du wirst es ansonsten nicht schaffen, Elm davon zu überzeugen, deine Applikation zu bauen. Aber ja, das ist aber auch immer gleichzeitig schon, dass das die andere Seite des Schwertes ist. Wenn du jetzt irgendwie mal einen anderen Weg gehen möchtest, kommst du mit Elm halt nicht weit. Und ich meine, es gibt in Leipzig oder so, glaube ich, hatten wir das, gibt es relativ viele Meetups zum Thema Elm. Aber so generell ist das sehr, eine sehr kleine, es sind sehr wenige. Obwohl, ich würde es gerne verwenden. Aber es ist halt immer so ein Ding, ja, ich haue jetzt dann irgendwie so ein Elm-Ding hin. Und am Ende stehen alle da vor und sagen, ja, okay, und was wollen wir jetzt damit machen? Wir können es nicht erweitern. Also bringt uns jetzt auch nicht viel.
Ich glaube, das ist was Ähnliches. Ich finde es schon eigentlich immer gut, wenn man so nah wie möglich.
Ja gut, aber dann ist das schwierig. Ich meine, jedes Framework, was du dann verwenden, das wird irgendwann wieder ersetzt werden müssen.
Ja, also ich habe auch persönlich immer so ein Problem mit so Präprozessorsprachen, weil am Ende kannst du nie die Granularität und Expressivität der Endsprache, also das eigentliche Kerns erreichen. Und du kannst zwar neue Abstraktionen draufbauen und ja andere Konzepte, aber am Ende die absolute Kontrolle, also zum Beispiel auch als dieses Hamel so rauskam so, ja irgendwie diese HTML-Tags und sind ja doof und wir machen das jetzt alles über Wide Space-Einrückung und machen so eine DSL dafür. Am Ende habe ich mich immer so eingeschränkt von diesem Hamel gefühlt und du konntest bestimmte Sachen einfach nicht machen, die du in HTML machen kannst, die standardkonform sind und denken mir so, nein, geben wir aus dem Weg Tool. Das ist wahrscheinlich bei C, wo du dann auch den Maschinencode direkt so reinhacken kannst, überall wo immer noch so, wenn du dich anstrengst und alles ordentlich machst, dann passiert nichts Böses, aber wenn du irgendwie so den schnellen Weg brauchst oder irgendwie nochmal so.
Hier, die Abkürzung.
Die Abkürzung natürlich auch gerne benutzt. Ja, aber Elms ja, muss man wahrscheinlich auch noch dazu sagen, ist ja auch sehr stark funktional.
Rein funktional.
Rein funktional. Und das ist wahrscheinlich auch, was viele erstmal so ein bisschen abschreckt, weil ich glaube schon der Standardeinstieg immer noch so objektorientiert für die meisten erfolgt ins Programmieren, was ja auch für dieses Verständnis, das war ja bei mir auch so. Ich glaube das erste Mal, dass ich so diese Beziehung da hergestellt habe, war, als ich mit Flash und Action Script zu tun hatte, weil ich dann hatte ich so einen Kreis.
Das ist ja auch eine ECMA-Script-Implementierung.
Und dann hatte ich den Kreis auf dem Bildschirm und dann hat da in einer Variable die Farbe geändert und dann hat sich das dargegeben und die Koordinaten und so und dann hat es so zum ersten Mal so klick gemacht, ah objektorientiert macht ja auch Sinn und da ist ein Objekt und jetzt kann ich dieses Objekt da und so weiter, ne? Und mache eine neue Instanz und dann so eine Zweikreise, super.
Leider lässt sich halt nicht jedes Problem so abbilden, ne?
Genau, das ist das eine. Aber wie gesagt, dadurch, dass glaube ich für die meisten immer noch so dieser Einstieg OO ist, wirkt ein funktionales Programmieren erstmal etwas alien und fremd, war bei mir genauso, weil ich hab ja auch mit Ruby und JavaScript und so vor allen Dingen OO programmiert. Und mich musste man auch zur funktionalen Erkenntnis erstmal überreden und dann, wenn man erstmal da war, will man auch eigentlich nicht mehr wieder zurück. Aber diese Erkenntnis, die kann man auch nur mit guten Zureden dann vermitteln.
Das ist aber bei JavaScript besonders gefährlich, die Objektorientierung. Also Objektorientierung, weil wenn man in JavaScript von Objekten spricht, dann ist es halt was anderes, als wenn man in Java von Objekten spricht. Und die neuen, auch gerade in ECMAScript 6, haben sie jetzt halt angefangen, diese Klassen-Syntax noch so weiter in die Richtung zu portieren. Und wenn man dann im Hintergrund sich anguckt, was dann tatsächlich, wenn man das mal auf ES5-Zusammendampf dabei rauskommt, dann das ist wirklich, das hat halt nichts damit zu tun. Und im Zweifel, also es gibt zum Beispiel solche extremen Ansätze, wie der Herr Crockford zum Beispiel vertritt es halt, benutze keinen Disk-Kontext. Also du kannst ja quasi irgendwie eine Klasse aufmachen. Und dann hast du deinen Scope und das ist quasi das Disk da drin. Du kannst aber jedes Problem...
TH.
Ich mach ein Bennet-Ding.
Ja, ne, sorry.
Das hört er eh nicht. Also du kannst die ganzen Probleme auch ohne das verwenden. Das heißt, die Idee ist halt einfach zu sagen, du kannst auch JavaScript-funktional verwenden. Du musst halt ein bisschen Utilities rundrum schreiben, aber das geht. Aber wenn du von Anfang an oder wenn du einsteigst und dir natürlich solche Schranken aufsetzt, fällst du weniger hart, als wenn du versuchst, die Konstrukte, die versucht wurden, um andere Programmiersprachen zu imitieren, zu verwenden. Das ist sowieso auch so eine der Kernerkenntnissen gewesen. Da gibt es ja auch dieses legendäre Werk hier, The Good Parts, wo man auf sich... Ja, das ist immer das Gleiche. Ach, das ist ja so ein dünnes Buch.
Vor allen Dingen ist The Bad Parts der Rückseite der entscheidende Teil. Und das hat mich ja vom JavaScript-Programmieren abgebracht. Weil ich war flammender JavaScript-Fan erstmal so eine Zeit lang. Und dann habe ich dieses Buch gelesen und dann habe ich irgendwann diese The Bad Parts gesehen und habe mir das durchgelesen, nachdem ich...
Da gibt es auch schon viele Moloche. Also die ganze, ganze Implementierung der Arithmetik. Oder...
Also jeder, der sich mit Programmieren beschäftigt hat, hat sicherlich einen dieser Talks auf YouTube gesehen, wo die bizarresten JavaScriptischen Effekte geschildert und dokumentiert werden.
Ja, aber es ist gut, das zu verstehen, warum das gerade passiert. Gerade wenn man irgendwie so Vergleiche macht und dann die Type-Conversions irgendwie während der Laufzeit passieren. Und je nachdem, ob das jetzt der erste oder der zweite Comparator ist. Naja, jedenfalls ja.
Aber es hat sich viel getan, sagst du.
Das hat sich schon viel getan, ja.
Das heißt, es gibt mehr Tooling, um mit diesen Insuffizienzen umzugehen.
Ja, nicht nur JavaScript-Insuffizienzen. Dadurch, dass so viele Devices dazukommen und so viele Leute neu auf der Welt ins Internet gehen und die Alten ja nicht abschalten. Da sind Omis mit ganz alten Androids auch noch unterwegs und die sagen dann, ich hab was falsch gemacht und alle müssen wir unterstützen. Also bei uns stackt es sich einfach nur so auf, was wir unterstützen müssen, aber es geht unten nichts weg.
Das geilste ist ja, wenn dann auf einmal so ein Bug-Report für einen Samsung-Browser reinkommt. Du stehst da und denkst dir, wie es gibt einen Samsung-Browser.
Ja, und ihr wundert euch, warum ich mich aus dem Frontend zurückgehe.
Also ich wundere mich da überhaupt nicht.
Ich auch nicht. Das ist ja eine rationale Entscheidung. Man muss ja auch irgendwann entscheiden, ob man noch das Seelenheil oder die Entwicklung vor der Brust steht.
Ja, das ist doch Feigheit vor dem Feind.
Aber was halt auch gerade so ein bisschen nervig an dieser gesamten Historie mit den ganzen Versionen bei JavaScript ist, wenn man jetzt halt mal in der Lehre unterwegs ist, was ich hier gemacht habe, und du jetzt genau an diesen Konflikt kommst, also eigentlich willst du die nur erst 2015 oder 2005 beibringen, damit sie erst mal irgendwie einen Einstieg bekommen. Dann suchen sie irgendwie ihre Fehler, finden dann die sechser Varianten, dann funktionieren die vielleicht bei zwei, drei Browsern schon, dann funktioniert es noch nicht bei allem und du denkst dir so, warum wollte ich euch das beibringen?
Also ich hab bisher immer, ich weiß nicht, ob man jetzt wirklich noch VAR beibringen sollte, anstatt CONST und LED zu verwenden, sehe ich halt gar nicht so den Sinn darin. Also es wäre, wie wenn ich, ich hab angefangen 2013 zu programmieren, wie wenn mir da jemand nicht gesagt hätte, dass es CSS3 gibt, sondern ich, also das wäre einfach seltsam. Deswegen, ich halte es bei meinen Leuten, die ich beibringen und das ist natürlich nicht so regelmäßig so, eigentlich so, dass ich sage, wenn du einfach nur ausprobieren willst, machs eben in dem einen Browser, stell dir dort auch, das gibt ja Tools wie Glitch oder CodePen, stell dir da auch einfach ein, einfach nur so zum Ausprobieren. Machs in den Dev-Tools in deinem Browser. Und dann, das Tooling behandeln wir einfach an einer anderen Stelle, weil zu dem Tooling kommt ja dann auch noch dazu, wenn die Leute ein bisschen entwickeln wollen, dass sie sowas wie Versionskontrolle und so weiter lernen sollen. Also ich trenne das so ein bisschen voneinander und versuche schon so das beizubringen, was man dann auch schreibt, vor allem wenn es Vereinfachungen sind heutzutage.
Ja, aber die Frage ist halt eben sowas wie, wenn du dann einen Babel und so weiter mit aufsetzen müsstest. Und dann kommst du halt an den Punkt, wo du halt nicht nur hast dein HTML, dein CSS und dein Java-Skript oder Webpack. Und dann bist du halt ganz schnell an dem Punkt, wo du denkst so, äh, Mist, das ist sehr demotivierend.
Deswegen arbeite ich gern mit Glitch oder CodePen und sag erstmal so, mach da irgendwie, dass es für dich einmal da funktioniert und lerne da auch drin und das Tooling machen wir an einer anderen Stelle irgendwie zusammen.
Ja, ich mag ja JS Fiddle. JS Fiddle oder das andere Glitch.
Glitch ist auch ganz gut, ja. Glitch ist ein bisschen cooler auch noch als CodePen, finde ich, gerade zum Lernen, weil CodePen ist furchtbar. Mehr drauf passt, genau. Ja, furchtbar, ja.
Ja, ich mein, vom Aussehen ist das halt so eine Windows 95-Oberfläche.
Okay, dann...
Glitch ist das Gegenteil.
Ja, Glitch ist...
Dann würde ich nochmal vorschlagen, dass ich StackBlitz hier in die Runde schreibe.
Jetzt bin ich gespannt.
Das ist nämlich ein, wie soll ich sagen, auch so eine... Eigentlich ist das VS Code im Browser. Ja, das ist StackBlitz. Das ist ziemlich cool, da kann man auch ziemlich schnell solche Projekte aufsetzen, aber... Ja, die Problematik dahinter ist ja... Man hat in den letzten Jahren den Schritt dahin gemacht, warum diese Konfiguration auch so kompliziert ist, dass man weggeht von so, wenn ich meine Applikation bauen möchte, dann muss ich erstmal irgendwie meinen JavaScript von ES6 auf ES5 umwandeln, dann muss ich meinen CSS parsen, dann muss ich irgendwie das alles in einer Datei zusammenknallen, dann muss ich mein HTML dann noch richtig kopieren, und diese ganzen einzelnen Schritte funktionieren jetzt eher über die Syntax von, diese neue Import-Syntax, die man durch Webpack mitbekommt. Webpack ist quasi so der Ansatz, so ich machte keine Sorgen, ich kümmere mich darum, dir die richtigen Sachen an die richtigen Stellen zu schreiben und du konfigurierst mich einfach im Hintergrund. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie, das ist auch einer der größten Errungenschaften der letzten Jahre, wenn ich jetzt etwa eine Library importiere, dann sage ich genau, ich möchte jetzt diese Funktion von der Library und ich knall mir die nicht irgendwo in meinen Head rein und dann habe ich die auf wundersame Weise auf meinem Window-Objekt zur Verfügung stehen, sondern ich habe diesen Import und ich kann in meiner Datei nachvollziehen, welche Abhängigkeiten oder welche Verbindungen ich überhaupt zu anderen Dateien habe. Und das kam halt hauptsächlich durch das Webpackzeug dazu. Allerdings ist es wirklich verdammt kompliziert zu konfigurieren.
Deswegen irgendwie hat sich das getrennt auch so ein bisschen Frontend-Entwicklung. Also gerade in großen Teams, da gibt es einen so einen Frontend-Dev-Ob, der soll den ganzen Scheiß machen, von vornherein. Diesen ganzen Webpack soll er erst mal so für mich aufsetzen, dass alles funktioniert und ich gar nicht da rein muss. Habt ihr so eine Rolle bei euch? Gibt es jemanden, der sich einfach um den Webpack... Der Webpack-Manager?
Nee, da gibt es... Da wir hauptsächlich in Angular arbeiten, ist es so, dass wir mit der Angular-CLI alles abgenommen haben. Darauf haben natürlich die Frameworks... Da kommen wir zum nächsten Punkt. Das ist quasi nur der erste, der kleine Einstieg gewesen. Darauf haben die Frameworks wie React zum Beispiel mit Create-React-App oder mit Angular, mit der Angular-CLI oder mit Woo, mit der Woo-CLI, die haben alle solche CLI-Tools geschrieben, um genau diese Basis-Einstiegshöre zu nehmen. Das führt einen natürlich auf der einen Seite wieder dazu, dass man so einen Wendor-Log hat am Ende. Wenn du Woo verwendest oder... Bei Angular ist es einfach so ein Beispiel. Du hast eine Angular-1-Applikation oder Angular-JS geschrieben. Und dann kam Angular-2 um die Ecke. Und dann haben wir gesagt, das ist schön, dass ihr Angular-JS geschrieben habt. Ja, aber wir haben das jetzt alles weggeschmissen. Wir müssen jetzt noch mal alles neu bringen. Super. Wieso soll ich mich jetzt darauf... Oder beziehungsweise... Wieso soll ich darauf vertrauen, dass mir das von zwei zu drei nicht auch passieren sollte? Da ist auch sehr viel Vertrauensverlust entstanden. Deshalb hat, glaube ich, auch meiner Meinung nach das Angular sehr viel an Traktion verloren.
Und dieses Micro-Frontend-Thema ist total gekommen dadurch.
Weil Angular ist ja so ein... Es gibt eigentlich gerade so drei große. Das ist halt Angular, React und Vue, würde ich sagen. Das sind so die drei dominierenden UI-Component-Libraries, also React und Vue, und Framework halt Angular. Von Angular kriegt man halt noch so einen HTTP-Kline noch mit dazu. Da kriegt man Formvalidierung noch mit dazu. Da hängt auch TypeScript mit dran. Das ist schon der dicke Panzer, den man da auffährt. Deshalb wird das halt für kleinere Projekte nicht verwendet meistens. Weil man muss ehrlich sagen, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie meine, weiß ich nicht, meine To-Do-Liste machen muss, dann muss ich mir jetzt kein Angular ans Bein bieten.
Der Chat sagt, wir sind jetzt bei 15 links zu To-Do.
Es sind 15 Minuten.
Das erklärt die Probleme des Webfrontends.
Und vor allen Dingen ebenso diese Geschwindigkeit, wo wieder irgendwer mit einem neuen Furz um die Ecke kommt.
Wobei ich bin ganz froh, dass Meteor und Ember schon wieder wechseln.
Das stimmt ja auch mal.
Was war das mit dem Hamster? Das war Ember. Ich bin ganz danach eingestiegen.
Backbone.js war ja für Minimalisten wie mich.
Ja, backbone hat auch nicht nur gute Seiten.
Im Übrigen gab es vor kurzem von GitHub einen Artikel darüber, dass sie es jetzt geschafft haben, weil du von jQuery gesprochen hast, jQuery endlich rauszuhauen aus ihrer UI.
GitHub ist also ein spezielles Ding tatsächlich. Also die haben auch, die haben zum Beispiel auch was das CSS angeht, eine echt abgefahrene Variante genommen, das zu entwickeln. Die hatten ja vor lange, die sind ja irgendwann, es gibt ja so eine, je nachdem mit welchem Browser du operierst, gibt es so eine Grenze, an dem der Browser nicht mehr so effizient das CSS analysiert, wenn du das in einer Datei auslieferst. Die haben die irgendwann getroffen und mussten das in zwei Dateien ausliefern. Aber das waren noch ganz frühe Zeiten, als sie das entwickelt haben. Aber ja.
Aber was ist denn jetzt sozusagen der goldene Weg? Also wenn ihr es euch aussuchen könntet, so den Weg des minimalsten Widerstands, der Zukunftsträchtigkeit, des Entwicklerglücks, der Sanity.
Also ich nenne das ja immer Wegwerfarchitektur, ne? Weil du willst näher, das ist ja am Ende, es gibt bestimmte Paradigmen, die jetzt aufgekommen sind oder die sich geändert haben, die es dir erlauben, bestimmte Sachen zu nehmen und wegzuwerfen. Das heißt, wenn jetzt die neue Library kommt, dann ist dein Aufwand nicht ganz so hoch, das mit der neuen Library zu implementieren. Das ist halt so eine Art Wegwerfearchitektur tatsächlich. Aber dazu musst du dich zwingen, das nicht alles in einen Klumpen zu entwickeln, sondern du musst es halt wirklich ganz klar separieren. Das sind jetzt meine Komponenten, die ich für das Rendering meiner Applikation brauche. Das ist das, was meine Businesslogik ausmacht. Und das ist irgendwie so der Teil, der meine Seiteneffekte von meiner Applikation abhandelt.
Und darüber hinaus ein globales Style-Sheet.
Ja, ganz genau.
Und die Seiteneffekte, die kann man da nicht wenigstens ins Backend auslagern.
Naja, du kannst das theoretisch machen, tatsächlich. Aber dann müsstest du halt wirklich jeder... Also das Problem, der Hauptsicherheit zwischen Backend und Frontend ist meiner Meinung nach, dass jede Interaktion mit deiner Applikation zu einer Zustandsänderung kommt. Wirklich egal, was du machst. Du scrollst, Zustandsänderung. Du klickst, Zustandsänderung. Du tippst irgendwas ein, Zustandsänderung. Was bedeutet, das ist ein Seiteneffekt, den muss ich irgendwie behandeln. Das kannst du alles an das Backend schicken, wenn du, wie soll ich sagen, wenn deine Leitung performant genug ist. Das macht ja, glaube ich, Alexi jetzt gerade. Die haben ja quasi, du kannst ja quasi schon, die sieht sehr reaktisch aus auf der Backendsite. Du kannst da deine Zustandsänderung auf dem Backend kalkulieren. Das sind aber alles einzelne User-Events. Die schaffen das auch in 60 FPS, den Kram, die Diffs, wieder zurückzupumpen, um da deine UI richtig rendern zu lassen. Ob das skaliert?
Also das kann wahrscheinlich, aber eher Phoenix, oder?
Ja, Phoenix mein ich halt.
Manche Sachen will man ja auch nicht erst an den Server schicken. Irgendwie so eine kleine Filterung von Dingen.
Ja, nee, nee, das, aber das, ja, also, ja, okay. Wenn man so ganz sauber trennt zwischen Seiteneffekt und kein Seiteneffekt klar, dann ist alles ein Seiteneffekt irgendwann. Aber, ja, ich wollte ja nur fragen, ob man nicht vielleicht so ein paar Sachen...
Naja, gerade wenn es irgendwie daran geht, deine Validierung irgendeiner Form, wo du deine wirklich Business-Logik eigentlich im Backend pflegst, dann mach einen API-Call, hol dir die Validierung, hau das zurück. Da sollte dich glaube ich niemand dran hindern, das an einen Fleck zu halten. Das Schlimmste ist, wenn es irgendwie an beiden Seiten implementierst, und die eine Seite ist irgendwie so ein Diff, oder so ein bisschen anders als die andere Seite.
Doppelte Datenhaltung, doppelte Logikhaltung, das sind auch bekannte Übel aus 40 Jahren.
Ja, also das war ja, wie soll ich sagen, sollen wir noch ein bisschen weiter links droppen?
Ja, weil du bist, wir sind ja erst bei den...
Wir sind ja erst bei den ersten drei Projekten.
Weil du gerade auch schon das State-Management angesprochen hast. Und ich finde das ist halt so irgendwie ein bisschen strange, wie ich finde, mit den ganzen State-Managern, die es jetzt halt so gibt. Und dass selbst viele dann für so ganz, ganz kleine State-Sachen halt sofort diese State-Manager sich reinholen und dann darüber die Projekte machen. Und ich halt eher so den Ansatz fahre, wenn ich so kleine minimale Seiten habe, dann hole ich mir schon irgendwie mein View da rein, weil ich das irgendwie ganz nice finde, um mir dann alles fein anzeigen zu lassen. Aber wenn ich so dieses State-Management habe, wo ich weiß...
Also den UI-State. Also welches Pop-Up gerade wann auf ist und welcher View auf sein darf, wenn ein anderer View da ist und so was.
Genau und das ist, ich sag mal, bei mir relativ wenig, sehr minimalistisch würde ich halt meistens sagen bei Visualisierungen oder bei den Visualisierungen, die ich jetzt halt so gemacht habe, dass ich mir halt denke, so klar, ich kann mir jetzt irgendwie so einen State-Manager da wieder reinholen und noch irgendwas anderes mir anschauen. Oder aber die Sachen dann doch, wenn es wenig ist, einfach selber nachbauen.
Aber da würde ich ja sagen, bei so Visualisierungen macht es wahrscheinlich auch nicht so viel Sinn. Aber bei so Web-Apps ist das dann wahrscheinlich genau das, was dafür sorgt, dass man das überhaupt testen kann. Weil das Problem ist ja immer beim Frontend testen, dass genau du nicht weißt, welche States von der UI und welche Fenster wann auf sein dürfen und überhaupt. Und das also erstmal die Reflektion zu haben. Was ist denn jetzt überhaupt gerade offen? Das ist ja das eine, ne? Und dann überhaupt noch irgendwie eine Wahrheit irgendwo zu definieren, welcher View darf denn überhaupt wann, wo sein?
Na, wenn du nur eine Visualisierung hast, ist das vielleicht so. Aber wenn du halt mehrere Sachen hast und mit Filterlogik und so weiter, dann halt in dein Daten arbeitest und dann mehr so Richtung Datenauswertungsteile gehst, dann hast du halt ganz schnell auch ein paar mehr Dinge.
Und wenn du es selbst schreibst, hast du dann trotzdem den State an einer Stelle? Oder hast du den irgendwie...
Ja genau, ich hab halt einmal das schon machen.
Sollte man das erstmal erklären, was wir damit meinen? Also, wahrscheinlich die meisten kennen so diese MVC-Patterns, wo man irgendwie versucht, das Datenmodell im Model abzubilden. Dann hat man irgendwie die View, die das rendert. Und dann hat man irgendwie so ein bisschen Kleber, das ist der Controller. Oder was auch immer Helfer. Dann denkt man sich die nächste nette Sache aus, um irgendwie diese Lücke dazwischenzufüllen. Und das Problem bei Frontend, beziehungsweise bei so sehr komplexen UIs, wo man sehr viele unterschiedliche Zustände einnehmen kann, ist, dass die sich natürlich gegenseitig beeinflussen. Das heißt, klassischerweise gibt es keine isolierten Models, sondern die haben immer eine Beziehung zueinander. Und die haben im schlimmsten Fall auch mehrere unterschiedliche Beziehungen. Und wenn das eine Model einen bestimmten Wert annimmt, dann hat das eine Auswirkung auf etwas anderes. Sodass man irgendwann gedacht hat, ja, lasst uns doch bitte einfach in einem Model abbilden oder bei uns in einem Zustandsobjekt. Das ist wirklich ein immutable Objekt. Und das repräsentiert gerade den gesamten Zustand der UI-Applikation. Und was man dann macht, ist, man hat, das ist das MVVM, man hat dann irgendwo einen Visualisierer, das ist beispielsweise React, das ist VU, das ist auch Angular. Und der weiß ganz genau, wenn dieser Zustand aufgeht, dann muss ich mich so rendern.
Das hab ich mir bei meinem Chat selber geschrieben quasi. Das war auch eine schöne Erkenntnis.
Das ist auch gar nicht so viel Code, den man dafür braucht.
Das ist übrigens auch eine Erkenntnis der letzten 10 Jahre Programmieren, dass ganz viele Sachen, wo man sich schon komplett auf so eine Frameworks verlässt und gar nicht mehr hinterfragt, ob diese Menge an Code und Libraries sinnvoll ist, dass viele der Dinge für den eigenen, konkreten Anwendungsfall gar nicht so viel Code sind. Und vor allen Dingen ist es auch schön, dass man selber so ein bisschen durchgespielt zu haben, weil man dann auch noch ein besseres Verständnis dafür hat, ab wann man dann vielleicht doch so ein Framework nutzen sollte, weil dann vielleicht die Komplexität so ein Level erreicht hat, dass man selber alleine nicht mehr Herr oder Dame der Lage ist.
Mistress.
Mistress der Lage.
Das Coole ist ja eigentlich, gerade wenn die Entwickler von diesen Libraries dann anfangen, das nochmal entweder in Talks oder Tutorials selber zu implementieren, nochmal voranzutreten und dann die Gedankengänge noch mit erklären, was sie gerade meinen damit. Das gängigste Pattern dafür nennt man jetzt gerade Redux. Der vorhergehende hieß Flux. Ist eigentlich ziemlich egal, wie das heißt. Okay, ich muss Flux und Redux schnell in den Chat werfen.
Soll ich das machen, dann kannst du es erklären.
War Flux nur für React?
Na ja, das hat mit React wenig zu tun gehabt. Das war eigentlich von Facebook entwickelt. Und da war die erste Idee, diese Modelle in relativ flachen Objekten abzubilden.
Weil React ja eigentlich nur der View-Renderer war.
Genau. Und irgendwann sind sie dann auf die Idee gekommen, dass man das auch in einem Modell oder ein Objekt abbilden kann. Und dann hat man sich Elm angeguckt und hat ja gesehen, wenn wir das immutable machen, dann können wir ja quasi anhand der Diffs den neuen Zustand berechnen. Das heißt, wir können ja, wenn wir uns merken, wie wir die Zustände berechnet haben, dann können wir ja vor und zurück in unserer UI springen. Wir können zum Testen irgendwie einen bestimmten Zustand erzeugen oder bestimmte Actions oder Change-Sets darauf hauen. Und dann können wir das ja ziemlich geil testen. Und das hat dann dazu geführt, dass sich dieses Pattern wirklich echt ganz schön festgefressen hat in den zwei Jahren.
Das blieb irgendwie so ein bisschen. Und selbst wenn ich, wie Letty es gesagt hat, dann arbeitet man eigentlich auch nach dem Prinzip.
Das ist auch so eine der Sachen, wo man denkt, ja, das hat es jetzt einfacher gemacht. Das ist nicht mehr so kompliziert wie vorher, diese ganzen unterschiedlichen Zustände abzubilden. Weil wenn ich wissen will, ob dieses Pop-Up gerade oder dieses Model gerade visualisiert ist, dann gucke ich meinen Zustand. Wenn da True steht, dann ist es da. Wenn da False steht, dann ist es nicht da. Und was das beeinflusst, dass es jetzt True oder False ist, das ist ein Resultat von einem Seiteneffekt. Und das war's. Und das ermöglicht das aber dann klar, dass man den View-Renderer separiert. Das heißt, man kann jetzt beispielsweise React und Vue mit ein bisschen... Also kann man eigentlich ganz gut austauschen, wenn man ein bisschen... Also das hat noch ein bisschen was mit den Datenmodellen der Renderer zu tun, aber das geht theoretisch. Und das heißt auch zum Beispiel, die Seiteneffekte kann ich anders berechnen. Und ich weiß ganz genau, dadurch, dass in Redux hat man unterschiedliche... Das nennt man Reducer. Die kümmern sich um einen bestimmten Teil dieses Objekts oder dieses Zustandobjektes. Und jedes Mal, wenn eine neue Aktion reinkommt, die von den Seiteneffekten oder von deinem View-Layer ausgelöst wird, dann werden alle Reducer angesprochen. Und Reducer, die sich quasi dafür nicht interessieren oder die Funktionen, die diesen neuen Zustand berechnen, die ignorieren das einfach und geben den vorherigen Zustand wieder zurück. Und die, die sich dafür interessieren, die können ihren Zustand dann entsprechend anpassen. Und das kann man super einfach testen. Das heißt, du kannst da relativ fixe Unit-Tests dafür schreiben und weißt halt auch, wie sich dein Zustand dann verändert.
Mir qualmt jetzt langsam die Birne.
Aber zum Beispiel bei der alten App, die ich hatte, die nicht nach diesen Pattern entwickelt wurde, sondern nach MVC, die hab ich jetzt neu geschrieben mit Redux, diese React Native App. Und ich hätte, bei der neuen könnte ich jetzt tatsächlich React Native, also ich könnte eigentlich den kompletten Store nehmen und in der Web-App nochmal verwenden. Und in der alten war das so verschachtelt, in dieser ganzen Hybrid-App, dass das nicht möglich war. Deswegen ist das schon ein sehr geiles Pattern irgendwie.
Das war jetzt der Bericht vom Frontend.
Das, was uns Entwickler umtreibt.
Also ein Teil davon.
Ein Teil davon, ja. Naja, ich hab zum Beispiel nur für Testing und so draufgeschrieben.
End-to-end-Tests.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall, finde ich ja, immer das spannendste Thema, weil das ist wirklich was, was die größte Zeit der IT-Entwicklung ja etwas stiefmütterlich behandelt war. Weil Backend, finde ich ja so toll, weil man alles super testen kann und genau sagen kann, ey, wenn du mir dieses Jason schickst, garantiere ich dir, dass du dieses Jason zurückkriegst. Und wenn dann irgendjemand kommt und sagt so, ja, aber hier kommt irgendwas anderes zurück, ja, was hast du mir denn für einen Jason geschickt? Guck mal, das ist ja gar nicht das, was ich da in die Doku geschrieben hab, siehst du? Wenn du mir das richtige schickst, dann klappt's auch. Aber beim Frontend, da ist das halt lange Zeit eben nicht so gewesen, dass du eben genau nicht diese Kontrolle oder diese Introspektion über States hast oder welches Fenster gerade offen ist und in welchem Zustand das ist. Und deswegen haben die Leute das auch nicht getestet. Und dann gab's halt so bei abnormalem Nutzerverhalten auch abnormales UI-Verhalten. Und Reproduzierbarkeit ist ja dann auch mal so ein Problem. Ja, bei mir, also wenn ich da alles so klicke, wie ich weiß, dass es funktioniert, dann geht's. Dann schreibt ja ein User, ja, aber bei mir alles ganz anders. Und wenn man das mal so ein bisschen systematischer angeht, würde ich das auf jeden Fall für eine große Verbesserung, also ich hab's ja selber noch nie verwendet, aber das klingt zumindest sehr sinnvoll, was ihr da so berichtet. Und das würde ja dann wirklich auch ermöglichen, mal so ein bisschen UI-State zu reproduzieren vor allen Dingen. Weil das ist ja dann beim Bugfixen immer die Königsdisziplin, wenn man es reproduziert bekommt, dann ist das mit dem Bugfixen auch einfach, wenn man es nicht hinbekommt.
Wobei du natürlich oft an Cross-Browser-Issues und irgendwelche CSS-Sachen stößt, die genau in irgendwelchen Breiten jetzt so und so nicht auffdauen, das sind eigentlich die meisten Bugs. Wenn dir ein Model nicht aufgelten und es geht in jedem Browser, das passiert, dann fällt einem das auch so eigentlich relativ schnell auf.
Das stimmt auch wieder.
Diese ganze andere Tests, also Unit-Tests sind schon gut, aber ich würde sagen fürs Frontend, der andere Teil, wenn der automatisch getestet werden könnte, das wäre noch viel geiler.
Naja, es kommt drauf an, wie weit du das fassen willst. Also Unit-Tests oder auch einzelne Komponenten lassen sich eigentlich ziemlich gut testen, wenn man da wirklich... Und das ist halt auch so, dass du irgendwie einen Test laufen lässt. Und im optimalen Fall ist das richtige Ergebnis drinne. Dann machst du einen Snapshot davon. Wenn der Entwickler... Du schreibst in deinem Unit-Test auch, was du annimmst, was richtig wäre. Und den gleichen Zustand kannst du natürlich auch im Frontend sagen, wenn folgende Dom-Struktur eintritt mit folgenden Attributen oder folgenden Style-Attributen auch drauf, dann halte ich das für richtig. Das ist ja nur deine Interpretation. Am Ende kann natürlich auch dein Unit-Test falsch sein.
Das ist natürlich auch jederzeit möglich.
Und dann machst du währenddessen, du lässt das rendern, machst dann nochmal so einen Snapshot und vergleist einfach die Snapshots. Und dann kann der Differ dann genau sagen, ja, das und das hat sich jetzt gerade geändert. Und damit kannst du auch relativ gut.
Im Endeffekt, wo man dann am meisten dran sitzt, heißt, es geht in der alten Safari oder Firefox-Version nicht. Und dann musst du eben genau in dem Browser nachschauen, auf welcher Auflösung, auf welchem Betriebssystem, in welcher Breite dein Fenster plötzlich Scheiße angezeigt wird. Und der State ist korrekt und das Markup ist korrekt, aber irgendwas wird nicht grenzen. Also das sind leider auf die Sachen, wo ich viel, viel, viel Zeit.
Ihr nutzt zum Testen von Browser, Cross-Browser, Cross-Plattform-Sachen wahrscheinlich dann auch Browser-Stack, oder? Aber ich mein, wie simulierst du halt einen...
VMS, Window-VMS zum Beispiel mit den Internet-Explorern.
Also wenn ich automatisiert testen möchte, dann machst du, du kannst den Selenium-Hub selber hochfahren. Sauber alles, ja, Source Labs ist eine Variante, was man als Service verwenden kann. Naja, das ist auch so ein echter Schmerzpunkt, ist halt, dass du gegen mehrere Browser das testen möchtest. Aber du willst halt irgendwie nur einmal die Logik implementieren, um das Verhalten in den Browsern aufzurufen. Und da hat sich halt irgendwann Selenium als Antwort, also nicht so richtig als Antwort, aber als eine Möglichkeit aufgetan.
Als geringeres Übel.
Ja, da kommst du dann wieder auf den Punkt zurück, was bringen dir Tests, die flackern? Also wenn du einen Test hast, der im ersten Rand läuft und im zweiten nicht läuft, dann hast du überhaupt 0,0 Aussage. Und aufgrund der Treiberimplementierung von Selenium passiert das halt. Und damit muss man sich halt wirklich fragen, lohnt sich das überhaupt zu verwenden?
Ist da nicht die eigentliche Antwort, einfach zu sagen, pass auf, diese Web-App...
Läuft in Folgen, da können wir...
Kann Fehler enthalten. Früher war das ja auch so, dass die Webseiten gesagt haben, hier, wenn du mit was anderem außer Internet-Exploder oder Netzgeber-Navigator ankommst, dann geh mal Stoffwechsel-Endprodukte entsorgen, um es nett zu formulieren. Dann würde es für mich negativ ausfallen, dass jetzt jede Webseite schreibt, installieren Google Chrome, worauf ich nicht so Bock hätte.
Da gibt es ja dieses, dein geschätztes Tool Slack geht ja damit um, das einfach in so einen Elektron-Container reinzustecken. Das kann man auch machen, das hat aber auch nicht nur der Anspruch da, ja geil, eine richtige App, aber irgendwie verhält sie sich wie eine Webseite. Das ist aber nicht das, was ich erwartet hatte. Aber noch mal als letzten Möglichkeit für Integration und End-to-End ist, das nennt sich Cyprus, um den drölfstigsten Link zu droppen. Aber ich glaube, dann sind wir auch durch.
Zählt hier noch jemand links?
Aber jetzt könnt ihr mal sehen, was für eine Arbeit in sowas wie diesen Podlove-Webplayer fließt, der wie viel Seele und Kraft da und Schmalz und Schweiß investiert wird, um das möglich zu machen, was ja dann vielleicht auch wieder die Leute dazu animiert. Ah ja, gut, dass sich jemand darum kümmert. Hier habt ihr mal ein paar Euro, damit das mit den Schmerzen nicht ganz so schlimm ist. Und danke für eure tolle, aufaufragungsvolle Arbeit.
Geld haben wir.
Ich glaube, die haben halt abgeturnt gerade.
So ein Open Source Projekt kannst du halt nur so bedingt mit Geld wirklich machen, weil nicht, dass jetzt nicht so ein gewisser Spendenfluss hilfreich sein könnte, wenn man jetzt wirklich energisch angeht und regelmäßig Treffen macht und damit Reisekosten oder sowas abdecken will und irgendwie einen Tisch voller Brötchen oder eben solche Geekends. Das ist sicherlich machbar. Aber ich denke, es hat mehr mit Mitmachen zu tun. Das ist, glaube ich, noch wichtiger.
Oder habe ich was falsches gesagt?
Du wolltest lieber Geld. Wieder nur Karma-Punkte. So, was haben wir denn noch hier?
Ich habe noch zwei Themen, aber zwei ganz kurze. Ich weiß nicht, ich komme ja aus einer, also die beiden Themen hängen miteinander zusammen, ich komme ja aus einer, wie soll ich sagen, nicht so dicht besiedelten Gegend wie Berlin, mutmaßlich Thüringen genannt, die...
Ein Land ohne Prominente.
Ein Land ohne Prominente. Ja, und wir haben auch Internet. Wir haben auch VDSL. Ich hab auch irgendwie das Gefühl, das ist genau das gleiche Gefühl, ich hab letztens überlegt, 100 MBit runter, 40 MBit hoch, das hatte ich irgendwie auch schon vor drei Jahren, da hat sich auch überhaupt nichts entwickelt. Dann hat mich aber mein Internetanbieter, weil die Telekom hat nämlich so kleinere Städte, wie jetzt zum Beispiel Ruderstadt oder Weimar, die jetzt so eine Einwohnerzahl von 60 bis so 20.000 irgendwie in der Träge haben, haben die halt gesagt, ja, das lohnt sich aber jetzt nicht so wirklich, euch zu versorgen, wir geben mal diese Kästen, die ihr braucht zum VDSL machen, ab an andere Unternehmen. Was eigentlich eine ganz schicke Idee ist, wir haben jetzt sowas, das nennt sich die Thüringer Netcom, vielleicht gibt es ja auch ein paar Hörer, die dort arbeiten oder da auch betroffen sind, dann bitte ich, das zu entschuldigen. Ich habe aber mit diesen, also das Ding ist, wir haben keine Konkurrenz. Also das heißt, wenn du Internet haben willst, dann kannst du entweder 16.000er von der Telekom kriegen oder 100.000er von der Thüringer Netcom. Da ist natürlich die Entscheidung relativ klar, was man macht. Der Preis derselbe und ich finde es ja eigentlich auch ganz cool, dass es irgendwie so einen lokalen Anbieter gibt, der das unterstützt. Bis ich vor vier, fünf Wochen irgendwann relativ viele Abbrüche bei mir privat bei meinem Internetanschluss hatte, haben wir irgendwann bei der Hotline angerufen und meinten so, ach ja, sie hatten über die Nacht so 300 neue Syncs. Ich so, ja, da scheint ja irgendwas nicht zu stimmen. Haben sie denn irgendwas geändert? Ja, wir schicken mal den Techniker los. Irgendwann kam dann auch der Telekom Techniker bei mir vorbei, die Leitung durchgemessen, ging alles. Dann ging das wieder zurück an die Hotline und der Bug-Fix war dann am Ende, dass sie mich auf 75.000 runtergesteckt haben. Das heißt, jetzt habe ich weniger Internet als vor drei Jahren. Also so viel dazu, es wird alles schlecht, das stimmt schon irgendwie. Da habe ich dann nochmal...
Mich hört ja auch sonst immer keiner.
75.000 runter und 17.000... Der Downstream ist mir ziemlich egal, ich hätte gerne die 40.000 abwieder. 17.000. Und ich rief an und meinte dann so...
Betroffene Minen der Beta...
Und meinte dann so, ja, aber es muss doch irgendeinen Grund geben, es hat ein Jahr lang jetzt mit der Konfiguration funktioniert, da muss sich doch irgendwas geändert haben. Die Leitung ist es nicht, die haben sie schon durchgemessen. Und es konnte mir keiner beantworten. Ja, wieso, sie sind jetzt nicht zufrieden, das ist doch wieder stabil, was haben sie denn? 75.000 runter, das reicht doch wohl locker.
Warte mal, das war eine DSL-Leitung. Und das war, du hattest 100 slash 40 von diesem Thüringen Bruder.
Thüringer Netcom, gleicher Anbieter.
Und das ist auch deren Leitung gewesen?
Naja, die letzte Schrecke machte die Telekom, aber die Kästen dahinter, die betreuen die.
Naja, bei VDSL 2 ist es ja Vektoring. Das heißt, die Kiste ist technisch komplett unter Kontrolle der Telekom.
Ja, aber sie ist ja gemietet von der...
Ja, aber die machen da technisch nichts. Weil die Telekom muss das technisch machen, wenn die Telekom über denselben Verteiler noch andere...
Nee, nee, ich kriege ja nur ADSL von der Telekom. Ich kriege ja kein VDSL von der Telekom.
Wie, warte mal nochmal, du kriegst jetzt... Du würdest von der Telekom nur ADSL bekommen.
Aber... Wieso?
Warte mal. Ich versuche das gerade zu verstehen.
Jetzt ist der Moment, wo Clemens...
Ja, es ist Wild Clemens Appears.
Reifen quietschen.
Ja, unklar. Also ich hatte hier so diesen Effekt, dass bei mir das... Ich hatte halt normales VDSL, also 1050, jetzt nicht in der Mitebene, sondern einen anderen Standort und da stellten sie dann generell auf Vectoring um. Teilt sie mir mit, dass da Maßnahmen ergriffen werden. Ich hab jetzt nichts anderes beantragt und auf einmal purzelte mein Internet zuhause runter von 50-10 auf irgendwas mickriges, unverantwortliches, schäbiges. Und stellte sich raus, nachdem ein netter Telekom-Techniker sich das auch mal alles angeschaut hat, stellte sich raus, dass meine Verbindung im Haus, von dem Ort, wo Dings rauskommt, in Keller, dass die wohl falsch gepolt war. Da war nur einer von den beiden verbunden. Mit der alten Technik kriegte ich da 50-10 raus, nachdem sie aber auf VDSL, also auf eine neue andere Technik, die andere Toleranzen hat, umgestellt haben, musste ich das fixen. War dann einfach, finden, fixen, und so weiter, war alles gut so, aber sowas kann es halt auch sein. Im Sinne von es hat sich doch nichts geändert. Aber du hast ja vorher schon 100, 40 bekommen, und dann müsste es eigentlich auch gehen.
Telekom-Techniker hat die Leitung durchgemessen, meinte, ja, es tut dir jetzt alles nicht verändert, ist wieder abgezogen. Ja, und dann sitzt sie da und sagt, so, was mach ich jetzt? Außer dir. Ich hab jetzt so einen freitaglichen Ritus eingeführt. Wenn ich von der Arbeit komme, ruf ich erst mal bei der Hotline an und frag mal, was so wieder passiert ist, macht das Ticket wieder auf. Aber ich, ja, du kommst...
Gleich vorbeifahren, wo die sitzen, mit den Nerds, also die in der Mittagspause abpassen und sich mal zu denen an den Tisch setzen und rausfinden, wer da im Nock arbeitet und dann irgendwie den kurzen Dienstweg suchen.
Wie heißt dieser Anbieter?
Thüringer Netcom.
Ist Fritzbox-Router. Der war auch... Der meinte dann so, ja, ich komm irgendwie nicht auf ihre Fritzbox. Ich so, na, hoffentlich kommen sie nicht auf meine Fritzbox.
Aber jetzt zu dem Thema Prominente aus Thüringen, also aktuell gibt es vielleicht keine, aber sonst kommt ja da das Who is Who, äh, also Bach, Brahms, Otto Dix, Ja, damals. Walter Cotius, Martin Luther, Goethe, Schiller, Einhalten hier mit Martin Luther. Richard Wagner, Karl Zeiss, also das ist ja, ne, also damals.
Ja, haben die Nazis jetzt alle verjagt.
Schiller haben die Nazis verjagt.
Ja, aber es war mal nicht schlecht.
Es war ganz gut, ja.
Alex hält die Pfanne hoch.
Genau, und ja, also mein Leid, es wird weniger Internet. Und das Letzte, was ich noch sagen wollte, oder beziehungsweise das letzte Thema, was ich noch hätte, wäre, dass wir jetzt versuchen, jetzt in Jena, was ja so ein kleiner Entwickler, ein kleines Dorf in Thüringen, was Entwicklung betreibt, haben wir dir das JavaScript Meetup, also nicht ich, aber unterschiedliche Firmen haben das eingeleitet. Und falls man da, oder falls Hörer aus der Region da teilnehmen wollen, würde ich mir sehr freuen. Wir sind nicht so viele, ja.
Vielleicht machst du so tatsächlich einen Web-Entwicklung.
Nein, nein, wir brauchen zwei Hände.
Vielleicht solltest du die ganzen Abkürzungen, die er vorhin durch den Raum geworfen hat, noch mit in den Meetup-Namen mit reinschreiben.
Das wäre gut, da wären wir besser auffindbar.
Aber wenn es nur einen Skip in jenen, kannst du auch einfach Software-Entwicklung jener machen.
Es gibt ja, wie wenn es nur eins was gibt, ein Meetup oder ein Framework.
Ein Meetup für JavaScript?
Jeder nur ein Framework.
In Berlin gibt es mehrere für verschiedene Frameworks.
Das ist für JavaScript genau, das Java-Meetup ist deutlich größer.
Ja, für Frontend-Entwicklung dann. Also einen HTML5-Meetup habt ihr wahrscheinlich nicht? CSS und einzelne Frameworks?
Alles eins.
Ein HTML3.2-Meetup.
Die versprengen.
Das gibt es vielleicht noch nicht mehr in Berlin.
Eine Geburtsstunde der Tabelle. Sollen wir durch oder sollen wir noch kleinigkeitenlos werden? Ich weiß nicht. Ist aber eigentlich nichts Wichtiges mehr.
Haben wir noch was Positives für den Schluss? War jetzt so ein bisschen negativ alles?
Ich kann doch ein bisschen Musik spielen danach. Ansonsten warten wir auf Apple, die jetzt am 30. Oktober wieder irgendwas preisen wollen.
Irgendwelche guten Nachrichten, die ich vielleicht habe.
Die sind doch echt hoffnungslos optimistisch.
Ohne Inverted Tea gehe ich nicht aus diesem Leben.
Ja, das ist wirklich nervig.
Nimm dies.
Nimm dies, Apple. Naja, dann heißt das, dass wir jetzt ans Ende der Sendung gelangt sind oder sowas.
Ja, reicht ja auch.
Dann haben wir unsere vier Stunden. Lustigerweise sind wir, vier Stunden haben wir jetzt auch gerade wieder erreicht. Das ist nämlich lustig, weil irgendwie bei Overcast, ich benutze das ja nicht, aber bei Overcast gibt es ja jetzt so eine Synchronisation auf die Apple Watch. Und die ist so gebaut, dass die maximale Länge eines Podcasts, die man da drauf finden kann, ist vier Stunden.
Wer macht doch so lange Podcasts?
Aber das liegt an der App und nicht an der Watch.
Das liegt an der Watch insofern, als dass es für diesen Transfer, den er da benutzt, eine Begrenzung gibt. Und der rechnet halt schon alle Podcasts runter, damit sie nicht so viel Platz wegnehmen. Und der, die Bitrate, auf die er sich da geeinigt hat, 100 MB ist glaube ich das Limit. Und der rechnet halt vier Stunden auf 100 MB maximal. Und danach sagt er einfach nein.
Bessere Kompression.
Ja, mein Vorschlag war einfach zwei Dateien aufzuteilen. Ich meine, interessiert mich ja nicht, ob das von einer oder zwei Dateien abgespielt wird. Muss ja auch gehen.
Ohne diesen Hinweis wäre diese Sette unterfüßt.
Das heißt, in der nächsten ATP-Folge können wir uns wieder darüber eins anhören, dass er sich über die Deutschen aufwirkt, insbesondere über Tim Pritlove. Ja, ich musste da sehr darüber lachen, weil ich das glaube ich beim Laufen gehört habe.
Da wurde sich explizit über Tim beschwert?
Es wird explizit in dem, also es wird immer erwähnt, wie sehr die Deutschen noch diese Chapter marks halt pushen.
Und überhaupt generell relentless sind.
Und was wir halt immer so brauchen.
Irgendwas hat er da gesagt, aber Tim wurde da definitiv bei ATP schon erwähnt, ja. Und im Übrigen ist der andere Podcast von dem Marco Ahmet, ich weiß nicht, wie der andere heißt, hab ich gerade erst vorhin gehört, Under the Raider. Ein sehr, sehr guter Entwickler-Podcast. Ich finde nicht, also ja, ich mache keine iOS-Entwicklung, aber ich finde, die haben so...
Auch generell gute Betrachtung.
Genau, gute Betrachtung ist nur ein kurzer Podcast von so einer halben Stunde. Also wirklich was zum nebenbei hören, kein Roman wie bei uns. Kann man sich echt mal anhören. Ja, wenn man mal vier Stunden putzt, auf jeden Fall.
Oder wenn man mal einschlafen möchte und so eine Auflistung... Also statt Schäfchen, Zähne, quasi, ja, was wir vielleicht sehen.
Früher hat man da Telefonbücher vorgelesen.
Oh, schön!
Ein Java Script Framework.
Das wär doch mal ein schöner Abspann. Die Frameworks auflisten.
Memory off und dann geht's in die ganze Liste der...
Es gibt Leute, die können P 100 stellen nach dem Komma.
Das machen wir hier nicht.
So was machen wir hier nicht. So, damit das jetzt hier mal alles zum Ende kommt, vielen Dank, Alex, vielen Dank Michaela, fürs Vorbeikommen, ihr könnt wiederkommen.
Bitte, bitte.
Ja auch.
Unbedingt wiederkommen.
Ja, wir haben jetzt einen sehr großen Kala, ich find das gut. Dann wird es hier noch bunter.
Ein Talaschäfchen.
Das war's.
Tschüss.
Vor tausend Jahren soll es sehr viele......Mittelalter-Märkte gegeben haben. Ruhe!